Wow, there's a whole videography thing about BTS.
(upbeat music)
What's good my beautiful hype beasts
of all things health and wellbeing.
I hope this transmission of goodness
finds you well and thriving.
My name is Rich Roll,
once again, in deep communion
with my literary minded eco warrior,
swimrun, brobarian, Adam Skolnick.
Snorkel mask-wearing friend of sharks,
rider of currents, pener of words.
Together once again,
and for those who are new Roll On
is our view a skew edition of the pod
wherein we prognosticate,
pontificate, expound and expatiate
on matters both noteworthy and trivial,
all buttressed with other bits
that have leaped across our transom,
underscored by a few wins of the week
and piloted to safe harbor
with listener questions dropped on our voicemail
at 424-235-4626.
Adam, how it goes you?
I don't know.
I am apparently unverifiable.
What does that mean?
Instagram can't...
Are you quietly petitioning Instagram
to get verified or something.
Instagram can't and will not verify me.
Therefore, I am questioning my own existence.
Am I me?
It's an existential void.
Is this all a simulation?
Your self worth is inextricably connected
to your verification status.
I can verify you, but that's all meaningless.
Does your verification of me
include a blue check mark or not?
The invisible a star chamber
that is the Instagram verification board
has yet to acknowledge your presence.
I do not meet their standards.
You're gonna just have to do more podcasts, I guess.
Is there another Adam Scholnick
that works at Ben and Jerry's?
That's my problem.
There are no other Adam Scolnick on Instagram,
therefore I will never be verified.
Maybe if you change your account name
to the real Adam Scolnick.
The real.
Official Adam Scolnick.
I might just go the other way and just go the real.
It's always funny when somebody on Instagram
has the account name official something.
Then you're like, but I don't even know who that is.
Are there a bunch of other pretenders to the throne?
Story of my life,
I don't know who is famous anymore.
The people I think are famous are getting less famous.
I mentioned your employment with Ben and Jerry's,
we should clarify for the record
because I think there's some confusion out there.
When we joked about that the other day,
some people actually believe that you literally
got off your shift at Ben and Jerry's
and came to do the podcast.
No, I did.
I do.
I scoop ice cream at Ben and Jerry's.
Now we're clear.
I just wanna make that clear to everybody.
Three days a week,
I work a Ben and Jerry's graveyard shift,
whatever that is.
In-between posting stories on the "New York Times."
Yes, in-between.
Sometimes there's downtime in the career
and you have to pick up an ice cream scooper.
But only the vegan flavors.
I won't even touch the dairy stuff,
which is a problem at my shift.
You have to talk to HR about that?
Like four days a week I talk to HR
and the other three, I work the shift.
I got my own scooper too.
I don't use the community scoopers cause it's pandemic.
So I bring my own scooper in.
That's never touched.
I weld my own scooper.
I whittled it.
I think there's a whole podcast
we could do on just this and this alone.
The wittler.
I don't know, I'm at a loss for words.
I will say since we since we last convened
and we shared about you out swimming
with that photograph of the white shark nearby,
that caused quite a reaction in people.
Yes.
We shared that.
It was interesting.
I was back out there again on Friday
and I've been in that area multiple times since then,
but it was back out there with the Malibu artists.
He said he was gonna post a video version of that,
but I haven't seen that yet.
No, I mean, we were out there
and he had a shark, we were watching him.
Before I got there, he was following a shark.
I got there, he's following a shark
and these swimmers were swimming right to the shark
before I even got in the water.
And as soon as the sharks heard them coming
or felt them coming, it boned out
and we saw it like disappear off video.
The swimmers didn't even know.
Because like I said many times before,
or I said last time, we talked about this,
there are swimmers that are there almost every day.
And it's, especially for triathletes
in the Santa Monica area,
there they're out there.
And so they didn't see the shark,
they didn't know shark was there.
Sharks saw them, took off,
which made me feel better about the whole.
On the Malibu artists account
there's video of sharks swimming
directly underneath surfers
and they're completely unaware.
That San Diego.
I saw that.
And he also is sharing with me
that he found this aggregation point
that the scientists and marine biologists
didn't even know about
at the shark lab down in Long Beach.
And he went up there to check it out again,
and we're talking about an aggregation site,
30, 50 sharks up north of Los Angeles
and they're out there in the night, all day.
We don't really know what they're doing there,
but different sized sharks, different ages,
most of them are like under 10 feet,
but still it's a big amount of sharks
and a 10 foot fish is still a big fish.
And apparently the shark lab was there on a liveaboard
and they were pull spearing tags onto the dorsal fin.
So it's like piercing in the ear,
except they didn't go and ask to have their ears pierced.
The benefit of drone technology.
The fact that he's been able to identify
these sharks that flew under the radar
of the scientists who are studying that.
And nobody believed him until he dropped the footage.
'cause no one believes just Joe blow off the street.
I'm the Marine biologist guy, I know.
And they didn't know.
And so then there was this ABC
did something on the area where I swim and they said,
there were a dozen sharks in the area.
He's never seen a dozen there,
he saw six there one day when I was swimming,
there was four there on Friday.
They're there.
Well you're looking good, man.
You posted on Instagram in your swimrun attire
and you're looking fit, man.
Thank you.
I'm in my Sands Neoprene swimrun attire.
I know, right?
Zuma is turning one soon.
Balancing your swimrun training
against raising an infant through the first year
is no small thing.
Dude, I am trying to stave off Dad Bot at all costs,
but it wants me.
It gets harder and harder.
But Zuma's first birthday is proof that I do exist.
When does he turn one?
At the end of this month.
Wow, congrats man, that's cool.
Yeah, it's cool.
And he's walking in
and he's vocalizing all the time
and he's saying some words.
Becomes like a real human.
He's moving from primate stage
to homo sapiens stage.
It's very exciting.
Very cool.
Thanks.
How are you, man?
You were in Telluride.
I was, yeah, I was in Telluride for four or five days.
It was a quick trip,
the occasion was attending a wedding there,
but we have some friends there.
So it was great.
Telluride is, aside from the fact
that it's just an absolutely magical place,
anybody who's visited there can attest to that.
It's really a beautiful part of the world
in Southwestern, Colorado.
It's not easy to get there.
And Julie had gone ahead of time with the boys, they drove,
I was following with the two younger ones
and we were flying.
We had a layover in Phoenix
before catching a flight to Montrose
which is still an hour and a half drive from Telluride.
But we only had a half an hour layover in Phoenix.
Our flight left late out of LAX,
we missed the connecting flight
and the next flight to Montrose wasn't until the next day.
So when we disembarked in Phoenix,
I went to the gate attendant and said,
"I don't wanna wait a whole day,
I'm just gonna rent a car."
But we had checked two bags
and I needed to get those bags back.
And they sent me down to baggage claim,
promised me that they would come through
with the rest of the luggage for the flight.
They did not.
I went to another gate attendant and they said,
"You're gonna have to wait two to three hours
to get your bags."
Sure enough, it did take three hours.
And this is because,
the airlines are in disarray right now.
They're laying people off, they're understaffed,
they're canceling flights all over the place.
They're laying people off and are understaffed.
It's because the economics of it
are all upside down right now, I guess.
So anyway, we left our house at like 6:00 a.m.
but we didn't leave the Phoenix airport
until like 5:00 p.m.
and ended up getting a pickup truck,
drove to Flagstaff, spent the night,
drove into Telluride the next day.
So it took a full two days to get there,
which was not great.
I mean, I love road trips;
my younger kids, not so much.
They were less enthusiastic about the whole thing.
But you drive through,
once you get north of Flagstaff,
you're in all this native country
and it's quite spectacular and beautiful.
You go through four corners up into Colorado
and it's magical.
And when you get to Telluride
it's like a real life Whoville.
I went on some amazing runs.
There's this gondola that takes you
from the old Telluride downtown up in the mountain village,
that's like free public transportation.
It's really spectacular.
It's like three sides of mountains.
You're in this like cauldron
and there's just waterfalls everywhere
and it's really magical.
The wedding was great.
It was attended by our mutual friend, Ted MacDonald.
Teddy Mac.
Just might be dropping by later today.
More about Ted a little bit later.
But yeah, it was great.
My wife is still there, the boys stayed longer too.
They just got back last night.
It was really a cool experience,
but there was some interesting things
that happened when I was there,
not the least of which was
there was a death on the Via ferrata,
do you know what the Via ferrata is?
I do not.
So Via ferrata is a term,
I don't know the exact translation,
but it's a general term for climbs
where there are cables kind of pinned
into the side of a raw like rock face.
Like half dome has.
Sort of, and it allows you to kind of clip in
and go, go laterally, like horizontally along the rock face.
Oh, on the face.
So you're like thousands of feet up
but you're clipped in
and it's quite a tourist attraction in Telluride,
this particular Via ferrata.
And every time I go, people are like,
"You gotta do the via ferrata, you gotta do it."
It's like I'm being bullied into doing the via ferrata.
I'm terrified of heights.
I'm always like, "I'm good.
I'm not doing the via ferrata.
Stop with the via ferrata.
Just feel like I'll be trapped,
clipped in on this rock face,
looking thousands of feet down,
terrified and unable to like escape
or get out of it.
It sounds like a mafia.
It's probably why
I should do it.
Like in a mafia assassination plot.
Hey, Rich, come with me to the via ferrata,
and you don't need anything,
don't bringing anything.
They say you need to clip in, you don't have to worry.
You don't need anything, trust me.
We laugh and we just,
but there are tours like proper tours
where a guide will take you across
and it's all safe and you're always clipped in
and all of this,
but apparently two women went up on it
while we were in town
without a guide doing it on their own.
And a woman apparently unclipped
for reasons on unbeknownst to anybody
and fell to her death,
I think like a thousand feet.
So she's walking face down on this thing or whatever.
You're just kind of going,
you're like facing the wall
and you're moving laterally on a ledge.
And you have two clips.
So you unclip one to move
and you always have one clipped in.
So I don't know why this person
would have been completely unclipped,
but apparently that's what happened
and she perished.
I had dinner with David Holbrook,
who's the founder of a thing called Original Thinkers,
which has sort of Aspen ideas,
Nantucket Project sort of festival
that I've spoken at at the past,
it's a really cool event.
In Telluride?
In Telluride, yeah.
He lives there, he's a filmmaker.
The son interestingly of Richard Holbrooke.
And he's a filmmaker, he made a documentary
about his father called "The Diplomat"
that you can run on HBO.
Super interesting guy who was living in New York city
and relocated his family to Telluride in like 2013.
And his son who's 19,
he's one of the people that takes groups up
on the via ferrata,
he's like a really accomplished climber,
but he also participates in search and rescue.
So he was part of the search and rescue team
that had to recover this woman's body.
And we saw him, he was quite shaken up by that.
So yeah, man, that's stuff's for real.
But other than that, Telluride is just,
it's unbelievable, had a great time.
And I think what I wanted to share about that experience
is getting out of LA
and kind of putting some distance between me
and my work, et cetera.
It's one of those experiences that allows you
to kind of reflect on what you're doing with your life,
how you're doing it, things that you wanna change.
I did a bit of a life review
and had a bit of epiphany
around the systems that we have here at the podcast
and what we can change, what we should change,
what we should hold on to, what we should let go of.
And it really connected me to this profound
kind of tendency toward perfectionism that I have
and balancing that against efficiency,
because I think I have this proclivity
towards being a perfectionist,
this idea that I'm the only one who can do this
and I have to do it
and it has to be this particular way,
and if it's not, it's a failure.
And I think I've held onto that because,
or I've created a narrative around that,
that that has fueled part of my success,
but at the behest of kind of hamstringing us
in terms of how we grow and how we kind of expand
and the many ways in which
I think it continues to hold me back and the show back
and reflecting on how I could get
into a head space of letting go
of some of those things
so that we can work a little bit more loosely
and more efficiently with how we do things,
'cause I think there's positives
and pitfalls of perfectionism
based on my experience.
For me, it's allowed me to set a very high standard
and strive to adhere to that.
But ultimately I end up becoming the bottleneck
for every decision.
And now we're running this operation
where there's a lot of people involved.
We have a brand new hire, Dan Drake is here,
shout out to Dan, his first day.
And so that involves managing people,
that involves empowering people,
that involves a decision tree
where lots of decisions are getting made.
And we have a system right now
where I ended up having to yay or nay
a lot of decisions that I really shouldn't
be in a position to do.
And I think like it's part and parcel
of what leads to burnout and exhaustion.
Like when I was in Telluride,
I still had to get a show up.
And then the night that I was flying back,
there was a show going up
and I couldn't just take a break
because the post production cycle,
and I think a lot of people don't realize this,
is really protracted with this show.
We get this blog post up
and we have all these photographs
and how do we create,
it's like publishing a magazine for every episode,
because the web piece of the show
is kind of an aesthetic cornerstone to the whole thing.
And yet the truth is,
I don't know if anybody who listens to this show
goes to the blog post and the webpage
to listen to it or to watch it.
It looks great but we're spending so much time
getting that up on its feet
when truly it's not really that related
to moving the needle in terms of.
But you've always had that.
Like when I was a guest on the show years ago,
I was struck by how everything,
like the look is all very cool and stylized and unique,
and that has always been part of your package.
And I think it has set it apart.
It must've attracted visitors,
having that aesthetic has always been part
of your doing.
Sure, and that's what keeps me wedded to it
at the same time.
However, like when I listen to a podcast,
I never go to the website.
I think the percentage of people
that go and visit that page is probably really small.
And when you balance that against the number of hours
and all the toil that goes into creating that,
the question then becomes, is that worth it?
Especially when we're putting out a book every year
where people can have that experience in book form
versus trying to make that happen every single week.
However, in the process of creating those pages,
we're doing a lot of the legwork for social stuff.
But I wanna work towards a place where
as soon as we're done doing the podcast,
I can walk away and I don't have to worry about it,
which is the way most people do it.
Other people get it up on its feet,
you trust them, it's good.
You move onto the next thing.
And if I could free up that time,
would it not be better
to add another show or two every month?
Would that be more impactful or important
than creating this pristine web page for posterity?
I don't know, so that's just one of the things
that has been on my mind
and I'm not sure how to solve that.
And as somebody who's always been kind of a solo operator,
I struggle with growth
and the responsibility that comes with that,
because I think managing people and figuring out systems
really doesn't meet my strengths nor my past experience.
But this is what growth is, right?
So, anyway.
The other thing I will share
and we'll put the Telluride trip to rest
is on the way back, the travel saga continued,
because we made our connecting flight in Phoenix,
but in the Phoenix airport,
there was a guy who was kind of creating
a little bit of drama.
And I knew that if he got on our plane,
there was probably gonna be a problem.
He was sort of flagrantly taking his mask off
and he was hitting his vape pen.
In a lounge.
In the airport terminal.
Because he was trying to attract attention,
like his goal was to be the center of attention.
Not only does he get on our plane,
he ends up sitting right behind.
And the volume just turned up to 11
on this guy trying to attract attention to himself.
And he was going to do it through charm or jokes
or the volume of his voice, or if need be conflict,
all of which ensued
to the point where finally
a gaggle of flight attendants descended upon him,
demanded his ID and told them
that he was banned from American Airlines.
And when we landed, he got escorted off the flight.
And when when we got off the plane,
he was sitting with a couple of cops.
And this is a weird thing as somebody who's been
a patron of commercial aviation for a very long time,
I've never seen anything like that happen.
But if you peruse social media,
it would appear that this is happening all the time.
It's one of those common things that you never see, right?
Like that video,
did you see the video of the guy
who got duct tape to his seat
after he was trying to fight?
I did.
I don't know
the circumstances around that.
People are on edge, man.
People are angry and
it seems that commercial aviation
is this Petri dish for acting out
in a way that seems new.
The commercial aviation is a capsule for acting out,
it's like the new subway.
It used to be like the New York subway
was the place that you saw the crazies
every once in a while
and now it's now it's taking to the sky.
Or it's almost like a pulpit
for people to act out in a very particular way,
knowing that they're gonna be filmed.
It's a stage.
I don't know.
The whole world's a stage.
It's the Shakespearian come up of aviation,
commercial aviation.
Theatrical production of shit
that goes down on airplanes.
I wish he had just gotten up and said,
"Listen, you can ban me if you want,
but I am doing the final monologue and Macbeth."
Well, the interesting thing is that
when he was told that he was being banned
from American Airlines, it was, he was gleeful.
It was almost like his goal was achieved.
And I'm like, that's such a strange,
he actually wanted that to happen.
So what is going on with the individual
who is so in need of that kind of attention
no matter the circumstances?
I'm not a psychiatrist,
but I will answer that question.
You are a Ben and Jerry's employee
in good standing is what you are.
I think that that's what you need.
You need to add another show,
it's just me at Ben and Jerry's just scooping ice cream
and talking with my coworkers.
That sounds like a new TikTok channel for you.
Anyway, before we move on, you are on TikTok now, sir.
I am.
First of all, the account Rich Roll
was taken by somebody who's never posted a TikTok
so my account is @iamrichroll.
And our boy AJ here in the house
has been creating TikToks for that channel,
taking clips from the podcast.
So I am there and it's growing,
people are enjoying,
like taking some of the best of the show
and putting it all.
Dude, we need a dance number.
Slivers up there.
But yeah, I haven't done a TikTok
in the true kind of spirit of TikTok,
like performing for the camera.
But my behind the scenes mentor on all things TikTok
is Joanne Molinaro that the Korean vegan,
she's my consult.
So I just have like right now,
AJ is handling it.
I haven't made a TikTok myself.
I should say that.
Joanne, we're gonna need three
of your best choreographers over here
and then we'll do a roll on.
The lighting, exactly, like we need something.
I don't know what that's gonna be.
Something has to happen.
Much that much to my children's chagrin,
I am on TikTok.
You're saying, Davey, the photographer, Davey Greenberg.
He's a beast on TikTok
sharing all of his training in the lead up
to his first marathon.
Dave's killing it.
He did his longest run today 10 miles at an 8.01 pace.
Yeah, man, he's gonna be ready to go come LA marathon time.
All right, let's pivot.
Let's do.
Enduro corner.
I love Enduro corner.
Yes, what have we got this week?
We got high peaks and cold water.
First up, we have to give a kudos Ravi Ballenger,
we're kind of checking in on him every week
in the spirit in which
we checked in on the iron cowboy.
He is closing in on his Colorado Crush update.
For those that are new
he's in the midst of this summer long quest
to conquer the Leadville Marathon,
which he did. Then he ran the Colorado Trail,
which is 500 miles.
Then he did the Silver Rush 50,
which was also in Leadville.
And he's almost completed summiting
all 58 Colorado peaks over 14,000 feet.
I think he's on 56 today.
As of yesterday, he had done 55
and then he's gonna culminate this whole
thing with the Leadville 100 on August 21,
but all seems to be going to plan.
There was one peak that he was very close to summiting
and then had something going on with his ears
or his eyesight.
He was only like hundreds of feet away from the summit
and he backed down and went back down
according to what he shared on Instagram.
So I don't know if he went back up that peak or not.
I'm a little unclear on that,
but he appears to be healthy and enervated
and excited.
Enervated.
Meaning low energy.
Oh, enervated means low energy.
Enervated, I think means drained of all energy.
I've been using that word wrong.
Somebody who prides himself on vocabulary.
Your vocab is one of your strengths.
Plead guilty to misusing that word then,
energized, I should say.
I didn't mean to.
And interestingly, it's being chronicled by Reese Robinson
who had a tenure working with us on the podcast,
making videos and stuff.
So shout out to Reese as well.
So we'll keep you posted on that.
In a similar sort of endeavor,
Scott Jurich made an attempt at an FKT,
his second FKT attempt on the Appalachian trail.
He set the record going south to north
a couple of years ago,
completing that trail in 46 days,
six hours and seven minutes.
This time was going north to south.
It's a 2,193 mile trail.
His goal was to do it in 40 days or under.
The problem was starting in the north
is there's these crazy elevation changes.
There's not a lot of opportunity
to kind of acclimate to that level of rigor.
And he ended up pulling out after a week
with a torn quad muscle, which is kind of a bummer.
Bummer.
So hopefully he'll heal up
and make another attempt on that.
The FKT for going north to south
is held by Carl Metzler,
who did it in 45 days, 22 hours, 38 minutes.
He did that in 2016.
And Scott's FKT going south to north
was bested by Carol Sob.
I think that's how you say his name, Sabi.
Carol Sob, I think is how you say it.
Who did it in 41 days, Seven hours and 39 minutes.
So he'd beat Scott's record by almost five days.
So Scott had really shouldered
a pretty ambitious goal with trying to do this
in 40 days or under,
and hopefully he'll heal up and get after it again.
Let's catch up.
Carl Metzler, that's the name
that's in the Goggin's book.
He won the hurt 100 when David
was trying to qualify for the first Badwater that he did.
And he remembered it.
I mean, he's a legend.
David remembered him coming down
and he'd just never seen a better athlete
at that point in his life
seeing Carl run these crazy slick trails.
I mean, Scott is an absolute beast.
So the fact that Carl has the north to south at 45 days,
I mean, that's wild.
They're both.
I mean, they're both.
These are two of the legends of the sport.
Sure, no doubt.
All right, well, moving from high peaks to cold water,
we're gonna spend a little time on cold water right now.
Is there an update on Lewis Pugh
and his Code Red Arctics swim?
His Speedo Diplomacy.
Speedo Diplomacy is good to go.
He got approval for his charter flight
from Reykjavik to Ilulissat,
but there were only seven seats that he was allowed to have.
And apparently Ridley Scott is sending a film crew.
So there's going to be a documentary
at the other end of this.
And so there was no spot for your humble reporter.
No seat for Adam Skolnick,
in a Ridley Scott.
The unverified are not invited, first of all.
And second of all his swim moved.
So originally I was gonna do this story
and it was gonna be around now
that I was gonna be out there
cause he was planning it for like the window
is opening from like the ninth or so.
And you know, when we were planning
this commercial flights were available, everything was open.
It would have been super easy to get there,
but now the swim is taking place on the 25th.
So the only way I could do it
is either only get there
for the first couple of days of the swim,
because it's a 10 kilometer swim,
but he's only gonna do about a kilometer
to a kilometer in half every day.
Because it's the coldest ocean in the world, basically,
it's literally right where the glaciers melting.
The ice melt that we're hearing about
is happening where he's swimming
and so he is going to be
in rough kind of mush ice or whatever it's called
that like where the glacier,
there's gonna be times where he's actually
in slush possibly, possibly doesn't want to be,
cause it's rough and not so good on the body,
but he's only doing about 20 to 30 minutes
in that water every day.
And anyway, long story short,
the swim starts on the 25th of August.
Zuma's birthday's the 29th of August,
I'm not missing.
I've missed a lot of stuff in my life,
I'm not missing my son's first birthday.
So I did try to get there after that,
I looked into getting out on the 30th
and trying to get there for the end of his swim.
Commercial flights are just impossible to come by.
There was a seat on the 23rd,
but again, that wouldn't work for me.
So one of your listeners reached out
and tried to get me through
like all the scientists and how they get there
sometimes on a National Guard plane the US provides,
all these different, interesting ways.
And they've been like a listener of yours
who's Danish, but lives in Norway
has been like calling Air Greenland for me.
I mean the community has come to try to get me there,
but it's just not gonna happen.
So unfortunately I won't be there,
but I'll be paying close attention.
It really is kind of the eloquent Al gore in Speedos
that we need right now.
And he's kind of different than Gretta.
Gretta leads with her fire
and Louis is really,
he's also very motivated as passionate
and as he's alarmed.
He's been doing this for a long time.
He's exactly where she is
in terms of knowledge of this stuff
and how alarming it is.
But he's just got a polished,
more of a diplomats kind of tone.
I mean, how old is he now?
I think he's 58.
Maybe he's a little older.
I think he's a little 52, 53.
I think he might be your age actually.
So for those that don't know this swim,
as you mentioned, a 10 kilometer swim
at the mouth of the Ilulissat Icefjord,
which is basically in Greenland.
The world's fastest moving glacier,
it moves at something like three meters a day,
near freezing waters, windchill.
It's crazy what he's attempting to do.
And he's been sharing on social media his training swims,
'cause he's in Iceland right now.
And he was swimming in some river the other day
and there was a drone shot above
that was pretty spectacular.
It's amazing what he does.
It's it's kinda cool to like merge adventure
with a mission like this
and, I would really want to,
I've been wanting to write about him for years,
just didn't happen this time.
That's the way it goes.
Pivoting to Antonio Argüelles.
So Antonio was attempting,
someone I know, who I covered in 2017
when he did the north channel,
the last of the ocean's seven
and he became the oldest at age 58
to ever accomplish the ocean seven.
He was the seventh to ever do.
Do you know what all seven of them are?
Yes, let's rattle them off.
Catalina, English Channel,
Gibraltar, Cooks, Strait,
Japan, is it Tsugaru Strait in Japan,
the Molokai to Oahu
and the North channel.
In 2017, he swam from Northern Ireland to Scotland.
So that's the North channel
and so that's the coldest one,
that's like 55 degrees, the one that it's really hard.
That's the one Kim Chambers came out of
and was like basically had
to be hospitalized immediately after.
It's 35 kilometers too.
Kim Chambers actually introduced me to Antonio.
They did a cross border swim
from San Diego to the other side of Tijuana.
I kind of remember her talking about that.
Right after Trump was elected.
So I did that story and then stayed in touch with Antonio.
And then I reached out to him,
he happened to be in northbound in Ireland
preparing to do the North Channel.
And so then we did that story and he made it.
I actually also ghost wrote,
something I haven't really spoken publicly about too often.
I ghostwrote his memoir, "The Forever Swim."
He approached me around the same time that Goggins did
and so I finished the Goggins' book
and then finished his.
I didn't even know this until this morning.
Well, it was published on the Spanish language.
So we translated it
and then now it's available in English,
I think on Amazon and also the audio books available
though he didn't narrate it, I wish he did.
He's really interesting guy.
He was inspired by the 1968 Olympics,
the first Mexican to win a swimming medal in the 1968.
And he immediately signed up for swim to get
into swimming at his local YMCA.
And then over the years,
he and his brothers all got into it and they sold,
like there was no good at that time.
It was hard to get a license to import goods
from other countries into Mexico,
it was a very controlled economy.
It wasn't an open economy.
And so they ended up selling on the black market
at these swim races, Speedo,
whatever they could get, good goggles, decent swimsuits.
He ended up connecting with the person
who the Speedo license in the United States in North America
and started to get the good stuff.
And over time there's high school career,
he was going to try to become an Olympian at age 17.
He narrowly missed making the team at age 17,
but ended up at Stanford through his connections
in the Speedo world.
He finished high school in the Bay Area
and was involved in the swim clubs up there,
one of the best swimmers up there,
ended up in Stanford,
but he just wasn't elite enough
to really make a splash.
And after a year, he quit the team
and focused on his academics
and ends up being a high up in government in Mexico.
And so his book is about his swims,
but it's also about kind of the modern history of Mexico,
which is really interesting
and his life story, so.
I didn't know anything about him
and he's old enough,
I think he's like eight years,
seven or eight years older than me
that we didn't overlap at Stanford.
And I read that when asked about
why didn't you swim at Stanford?
He said, "It wasn't the right fit."
And that's usually code for like,
I don't get along with Skip Kenny.
Anybody who has some connection
to the Stanford swimming universe
has heard some version of that story,
because Skip is abit,
he could be a challenging character for certain people.
So I immediately assumed that,
but that was not actually the case.
He got along fine with Skip,
what he didn't like was basically his role on the team
was he was breaking water for the best women.
And so he just didn't like being in that position
of not being good enough
and he felt like he just wasn't right.
And so he backed off and he doubled down on his business.
He ends up like getting the contract
to supply all the swim gear to the Pan-Am games
while he's still in college.
Becomes this wheeler dealer.
And he still is, but he is.
So anyway, he was attempting to do the double.
He did the English channel double.
He did the Catalina double in 2019,
became the oldest to ever do it.
He's 62 now.
And his goal was to then do the English double.
And it was a really glassy day flat day,
and he got to France in 13 hours or so.
He was doing great, came back,
got within two miles of Dover
and he'd been vomiting all day
and he hadn't been feeling well on his stomach.
And he started hallucinating,
which sometimes happens in these 24 hour swims.
He thought it was cause of the hypothermia,
although it was only like 62 degree water,
which is not cold.
It's cold if you're gonna be in it for 24 hours,
but it's not cold for him.
But he just wasn't feeling it
and he got a complicated current.
And so with two miles to go,
they made the decision that it was getting dangerous.
And also, apparently the boat was breaking down
and so he was drifting away from the boat.
He didn't realize the boat was breaking down,
so it was getting dangerous.
So he came out and then he got to Dover
and the plan was for he and his wife, Lucia
to then go to Paris and enjoy a vacation.
He always kind of does that after one of these swims.
And his stomach just wasn't getting any better
and it got to the point
where he couldn't even stand up
and he was rushed to the emergency room
and it turns out he had gallstones while doing this.
And one of the stones got in the canal between,
I guess, the gallbladder and the stomach, maybe.
In the duct.
And so it got into that duct and it was lodged there
and he ended up needing a procedure.
So he had gallstones and almost made it.
I mean, he's amazing.
That's wild.
Is he gonna make another attempt?
Yes, yes, definitely.
Well, speaking of cold water swims not going to plan,
our boy, Chris Hout,
my coach, coach's corner mainstay
made an attempt last week to swim across Lake Tahoe,
Trans Tahoe, it's a 21.8 mile swim in very cold water.
I don't know many of the details,
but on Instagram, one of his crew members
was sort of sharing clips.
It began in the dark.
I think maybe at something like two or three in the morning
or something like that.
And after a few hours of swimming,
Chris ended up with hypothermia and pulling out of it.
And all I can tell you about that
is Chris is one of the hardest men I've ever met.
So anything that fails Chris had to be brutal beyond.
So I had some texts with him this morning.
Apparently his kids were ill in the days leading up to this
and then he got quite sick in the day or two
at like 48 to 72 hours after this.
So he wasn't tiptop, I think,
it's basically what happens.
That's cold war.
He may be making another attempt in September.
I don't know.
But unfortunately that one didn't go to plan.
And Chris is, he's got that Nordic blood,
but that cold water, unlike Antonio,
I mean, Chris is very lean.
A lot of these open water, cold water swimmers
they put on all this heft,
they look all paunchy, they're fit,
they just need that subcutaneous fat to keep them warm.
Chris doesn't got none of that.
Antonio has what he calls bioperine.
Yeah, exactly.
Bioprene, that's good.
Chris was putting in monster swim sessions out
to get ready for this
so my heart's a little bit broken.
And all I gotta say is,
I don't know how these guys do it.
I can't stand cold water.
It's really hard for me.
And on the subject of cold water,
before we take a break here,
I gotta my new streaming obsession,
which is the show called "The North Water."
Have you checked it out yet?
I'm trying to get April into it.
We watched the trailer and she looked at me.
She goes, "Colin Farrell's in this?"
Yes.
So this is a new mini that streaming on AMC Plus,
you can get it on Amazon Prime.
I'm only two episodes into,
I guess it's five episodes total.
And it's a show that's set in the 1850s in England
about whaling, set on a whaling ship.
It does star Colin Farrell as just,
I mean, this guy explodes off the screen.
He's like a barrel chested, homicidal alcoholic,
completely feral master harpoon called Henry Drax
and he's just a savage in the show, it's unbelievable.
And then Jack O'Connell who plays this surgeon
on the whaling ship, who's suffering from PTSD,
from his experience being deployed
to the colonial war in India.
And he's addicted to laudanum
and he's kind of like the ballast.
I feel like in every 19th century drama,
someone's got laudanum,
someone's taken laudanum.
He's way down the rabbit hole on laudanum.
There was laudanum in the Berlin thing.
"Babylon Berlin."
And "Deadwood."
"Deadwood" has too.
And then in "The Knick" it's like opium
and heroin and morphine.
So they moved on from laudanum in "The Knick."
It seems to be part of the time.
Well, man, nobody knew better, right?
Why not?
There's a scene where he goes into the pharmacy
and he's trying to finagle extra laudanum
with the pharmacist before he gets on the whaling ship.
So he has a supply that's gonna last time
for the tenure of this adventure,
but this show is unreal.
Do you have any extra laudanum?
You already asked me that?
Did I though.
It must be pretty good.
I mean he nods out like it's heroin.
I don't know exactly what laudanum is.
It's like morphine,
I think liquid morphine or something.
And look, I gotta say, Colin Farrell,
I just think it's fascinating,
it's an extraordinary performance by him.
He layers this murderous nature
that he has with a certain kind of gentility
and the more I see him in recent things,
the more I'm becoming increasingly convinced
that he truly is one of the all time greats.
He's making super interesting career choices.
Starting with "The Lobster,"
then he did "True Detective."
Did you see "The gentleman"?
I did not see "Gentlemen."
He is on fire in that movie.
My favorite is "In Bruges."
I think that's a master work.
You can't take your eyes off of him.
And it's like, I mean, they get on this whaling ship.
I'm not gonna spoil too much of it,
but they start venturing north to Greenland
past Cape Farewell and into the Baffin Bay.
Maybe you could have hitched a ride on this whaling ship
to get up there to see Louis Pugh.
It doesn't look like a good time,
but there's plenty of laudanum the time pass.
And they kind of decamp onto these ice flows
and Colin Farrell gets off
and he's walking around on the ice just clubbing seals.
It's unbelievable.
It's so vicious and harsh and visceral and disturbing.
It's sort of like apocalypse now meets Joseph Conrad
with Warner Hertzog vibes.
More than a Revenant meets master and commander.
Revenant meets master and commander might be the best.
But which, you kind of,
there's a question there is like,
who is going to watch this?
Like, I liked it, you like it,
it looks like a massive production.
How much money?
I mean, they have a legit vintage, whaling ship
that they're literally on.
Is that like an eight million dollar production?
I think they filmed in the fjords around Norway.
I'm pretty sure they got the cheap fjords,
but they spared no expense on this.
It's super interesting.
Well, I mean, and so you love it.
So this is great.
I'm gonna watch this thing.
We have a cold water theme running
through this show today.
We're ice cold baby.
We haven't even gotten to the next cold water subject,
which is kinda hot.
That's true.
Yes.
Before we take a break,
I should say also on the subject
of things that I'm watching, that I'm enjoying,
I just finished "The White Lotus" last night,
which is amazing.
Have you been watching that?
No, I've opted out of "The White Lotus" so far.
You gotta check it out.
Really?
Mike White is a genius.
What did he do last?
What was his last thing?
He did that show in "Enlightened."
He used to have a production shingle
with Jack Black called black and white.
He's great, he just has this incredible ability
to kind of capture the zeitgeists
and create these characters
that are archetypes that are all identifiable,
like each person in this show,
you're like, I know somebody like that.
It's amazing.
I'm interested in being a long time travel writer
and seeing like some of these five star properties
and just kind of, so that aspect is interesting.
Well, he definitely minds the territory of colonialism
and kind of, like the idea,
it's sort of almost like "Westworld."
Like they go to this place
and they kind of artificially craft
this Hawaiian experience within the enclave or within,
behind the walls of a very fancy resort.
And they filmed the whole thing
at The Four Seasons in Maui during the pandemic.
No.
It was closed down,
they took it over and were able to execute
like eight episodes of this show
when everything was shut down in a short shrift,
like it looks like it all came together
and he wrote every episode.
I mean, the guy's brilliant.
Damn you Rich Roll, I'm in a reading phase.
I'm in a reading phase.
These are both very literary shows.
So you can use that excuse.
Let's take a quick break and we'll be back
with more interesting thoughts.
Sorry to interrupt the flow
we'll be right back with more awesome.
But I wanna snag a moment
to talk to you about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know actually
already know how to eat better
and aspire to incorporate more whole plants,
more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans, and legumes
into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools
and support very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly
and because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised,
I'm proud to say is The Plant Power Meal Planner,
our affordable, all-in-one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team
of nutrition coaches, seven days a week,
and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up,
visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual membership
when you use the promo code RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life-changing stuff people
for just a $1.70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com,
promo code RRHEALTH for $10 off an annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
And we're back.
Should we share a few parting thoughts on the Olympia?
Let's do it.
Where do you wanna start?
I think, for me, the final event,
which is the marathon, Kipchoge winning that,
running away from the field with eight miles to go
and basically sweltering, 98 degree
with 90% humidity type conditions,
and the way he finished it was just spectacular.
And then friend of the pod Knox Robinson
wrote something for the "Tracksmith" newsletter
that I loved.
I always love reading his stuff.
He's such a good writer.
He's amazing.
I just want him to write more.
But he had these quotes
from when he was at a training camp,
because he wrote a profile on Kipchoge for GQ.
But this kind of were outtakes
from a training camp when
he visited there in the rift valley in 2019,
I think it was, correct me if I'm wrong,
I think it was 2019
and he had this great quote in his story.
This is Kipchoge talking.
"In our place here, we actually don't believe in success.
We believe in great preparation,
which will be translated to success.
We don't wanna actually put success in front of our minds.
If we do, we are not doing the job.
We want to do the job first
and then success is realized."
It's so profound.
It's like, but like that's for everything, right?
Everything in life.
The work I do, I often think of results first
and then you have to stop yourself.
But like, it doesn't matter,
that is so immaterial of the process of writing,
of creating something great.
The creation of something great
is in the day-to-day process
like Dave is experiencing now with his training
and all of that.
It's like you can't worry about
what's gonna happen in the future.
Process over results, journey over destination.
And it's what you learn along the way
that kind of guards you for whatever success.
Either you succeed or you fail
and you learn something along the way.
It's like you leave it out on the floor
and live with it
because you've done everything you can do.
But detaching from that kind of goal oriented mindset
and just falling in love with the grind is the journey.
And, I remember from when Knox was on the podcast
and talking about,
I think he's made a number of trips
to that part of the world
and spent quite a bit of time with not just Kipchoge,
but like a lot of those elite marathoners,
experiencing how they live their lives day in, day out.
And it's very simple.
We get caught up in the gadgets
and the metrics and the goals and this and that,
and they're just literally gone out,
and like just the basics.
The habits.
Sleep, eat, train, run, have fun.
So apparently the other thing
that I kind of was struck with,
my last thought on the Olympics
were these two mothers that dominated
and a one is Faith Kipyegon, also Kenyan,
trains with Kipchoge or started to
in the last couple of years,
she won the 1,500 meter race five years ago,
and she was defending her gold medal,
but she also just had a baby two years before.
And so she's a mother
and now she's running faster than ever before.
She wasn't even necessarily favored in her race,
there was a dominant Dutch runner
that had won the 5,000, 10,000,
she was going for the triple
and she'd been winning all the races at the 1,500 level.
And she just took off the last 200 meters and dominated.
And her posts about what it was like
to get back to elite status
and to be faster even than before, as a mom,
really, really, really moving stuff
and how much it took
to get her body back into that competition mode.
And then Allyson Felix, of course, another champion,
the most winningest,
the winningest track athlete ever
in the United States history,
I think maybe in history, 11 metals.
She won her with her own shoe after she had gave birth,
Nike low-balled her on some offer.
Yeah, that was big news when basically she was pregnant
and the way that Nike works its contracts
with its female athletes,
there was something like a 70% drop in her salary.
And just basically a lack of long-term support
for people that are having children.
Basically, the message being like,
well, you're never gonna be back to form,
so we're just not gonna pay you.
And then now that she measured it
that created a big kind of hullabaloo.
Lindsey Krauss wrote a bunch about that,
that put Felix and into
kind of a mainstream conversation
around female athletics.
And to see her not only come back
and perform at a high level,
but to just absolutely crush it.
And that image of Alison walking with her daughter
to me is like one of the iconic images of Tokyo.
Absolutely.
She won, I think ended up being bronze in the 400
and an amazing race with the Bahamian legend,
she defended her gold.
Her name's escaping me, but she was amazing.
Alison came in third and then the four by 400,
the women just destroyed the field.
I mean, they were ahead by so much
and she was one of the members of that.
Now, like the winningest track and field athlete ever,
eclipsing Carl Luis' 10 medals.
And she did it wearing her own shoes, Saysah,
I think S-A-Y-S-A-H is the brand.
So say your sash, I don't know,
but that's her brand.
And so, props to two moms.
'cause you know, Serena Williams gets a lot of credit
for being the mom that's coming back
and how hard it is to come back
and be at the top of her sport,
and she's gotten to the finals multiple times.
Now we're talking about,
this is kind of the first time I can remember mothers
with young children actually winning gold,
get becoming the world champion.
I mean that's.
And also without the resources that Serena has
at the same time.
It's pretty cool.
I mean, it's cool that Serena's doing it too.
It's not too not to knock her,
but just as comparison as a yard stick,
that's the level these women are at.
Also shout out to Molly Sydell for the bronze
in the women's marathon.
Her second ever marathon.
Yeah, I know, it's crazy.
That's maybe the craziest story ever.
Second ever marathon or is that right, or third?
I'm not sure.
First ever was the trials.
Yes.
Yeah, is that true?
I think that's wild.
Pretty cool story.
It is interesting looking back on Tokyo
and I'll fully admit I wasn't wired
to the television in the manner that I have
with past Olympiads,
part of that is just being busy.
And other part of that is just being untethered
from we don't have cable,
so it's not as accessible for me
and the time difference.
There's a lot that's been written about
a drop in viewership.
I don't know how much of that
has to do with it being pandemic oriented
and just a weird Olympics in general,
versus this age of social media,
where it's impossible to not know
what's happening when it's happening,
the idea that you're gonna wait,
not no, sit down a prime time
and watch it unfold on NBC is just not reality anymore.
I think it's also lack of star power.
There was no Usain bolt or Michael Phelps.
I mean, Simone was there,
but she ended up having to pull out of some events.
So I think there was a lack of star power,
to be honest with you.
I think the idea that you can look at
like Nielsen ratings or whatever
and say viewership is down,
but I would suspect that engagement
was as high as it's ever been.
It's just that people are consuming this
in shorter clips on social media.
If it's not a YouTube where they're seeing
a little clip on Twitter or Instagram,
they're consuming it,
they're just consuming it in different ways.
So the traditional notion of gauging, you know,
viewership and engagement with the public,
I think is antiquated.
No doubt.
I mean, it's happening across all sports,
all major sports are having to wrestle
with this same thing.
And I still feel for the athletes,
like the idea that as soon as
you're done competing,
you have like, I don't know,
24 or 48 hours to skedaddle and get out of there.
The whole experience was shortcut
or truncated due to COVID.
There's a really interesting piece
that an athlete called Race Inboudin,
who's a fencer I believe wrote for The Guardian
and basically just giving his firsthand experience
of what it was like to be there.
This was his third Olympics.
And just lamenting the fact that typically,
the value of the experiences in all the people
that you meet and the encounters that you have
and going to the dining hall
and just meeting all the athletes,
it's like none of that.
It's like everywhere you went,
there was nobody there.
It was just lonely.
He had his teammates,
but a lot of athletes like feeling lonely and isolated
and on top of that,
he points a sort of finger at the IOC,
which is an easy target.
And it's inherent hypocrisy
in that it stands for supporting the athletes,
but really it's just about profiting
off the shoulders of the athletes
and not really catering to their needs.
So, I think there's some issues
that we need to unpack.
Alexi Pappas came by the house the other day,
who is an Olympian for those that don't know,
has competed in the Olympics for Greece
in track and field.
She made a movie called "Olympic Dreams."
And a lot of that movie is about being
in the dining hall and meeting all these other athletes.
And I said, you weren't here,
but like, have you talked to some of your friends
who were there?
And she just said,
"I feel bad for all those athletes there
that were kind of robbed of the type of experience
that made it so meaningful, you know, for me."
So anyway, cause that's what makes the Olympics.
But so anyway, LA is next 2024.
People don't know this, but you and I,
when we first started talking
about doing something together,
it was gonna be built around maybe going to Tokyo
and covering the Olympics in a profound way
for the RRP.
Should we roll out that game plan for the LA?
I think we should, man.
I think we should too.
We got time to plan for it.
I think it could be really great.
It's here, there's no reason not to do that.
You got friends of the pod
that could be really good, like Alexa would be great.
Of course, we could build a team around it.
I mean, yeah, I guess we can sort of say it publicly now,
but there was a plan a foot for us to take the podcast
to Tokyo, set up shop,
get a lead sponsor involved
so that we could get a location
that was either in the village
or just outside the village
and create a lounge where athletes
and all the kind of fancy people
that attend the Olympics could drop by,
eat food, hangout, and we would just podcast every day,
live stream it,
get these athletes off the podium
after they did their five minutes on the Today Show
to get the real story
and kind of beat the networks of their own game
by creating a really rich content.
And we were gonna do some narrative stuff too,
man, on the street stuff.
So now we have LA to look forward to for that.
Plenty of time to plan.
Doing a daily show.
But you gotta figure out where you're studio.
Where it would be.
Wherever like the kind of center of gravity is,
I mean, being inside the village is really,
I don't know that that's really
where you wanna be
because only the athletes can get in there,
but like any big event just outside of the village,
there's basically these locations
that corporations take over to create experiences
for the attendees and the athletes like to go there.
So it would be about figuring out where that might be.
Right around the UC campus,
isn't that where it's all gonna be.
I guess, I mean, LA is so sprawled out.
So it would be a matter of looking
at where all the venues are and finding.
I would assume,
is the village going to be down by USC?
They're building a massive,
another big arena,
like right next to the Natural History Museum right now.
I was just at the Butterfly Garden so I saw that.
Listeners Butterfly Garden is fabulous.
Sorry, I'm a dad now.
I don't know if you know,
I go to the butterfly garden.
All right, well more to be revealed on that.
Let's pivot to a couple more serious matters.
Obviously it's Monday, what's the date?
August 16th when we're recording this,
this will go up Thursday, the 19th.
As of today, we're in the midst of quite a bit of chaos
in Afghanistan with everything that's going on there,
just to kind of recap,
not that people are unaware of this.
After two decades of US occupation,
$2.26 trillion spent,
US pulled it's troops out recently
and the result is of course,
this power vacuum that's quickly
been filled by the Taliban,
which has moved unbelievably swiftly
to seize control of the entire country,
culminating in president Ashraf Ghani fleeing,
and the occupation of Kabul in the last day or two.
Taliban just took the presidential palace,
I think today if not yesterday.
We've all seen the scenes at the airport.
It's absolutely horrifying.
And a lot being written
about the Biden administration dragging its heels,
despite weeks of warnings,
being incredibly slow to extract US citizens
and civilians and embassy employees.
There's this delayed withdrawal
that's been causing death and chaos.
I don't know if you've seen Edward Snowden's rants
on Twitter right now, but he's like all over this.
Is he really?
Because apparently Biden,
there's an article that I'll link up about this.
But Biden had said,
I think just a couple of weeks ago
that the likelihood that there's gonna be,
the Taliban over running everything
and owning the whole country would be highly unlikely
and kind of really dismissing comparisons
to the fall of Saigon as being out of hand.
And of course, that's exactly what we're seeing.
I mean, he said point blank,
that Taliban is not the North Vietnamese army.
They're not remotely comparable in terms of capability.
There's gonna be no circumstance,
we're gonna see people being lifted
off the roof of an embassy
of the United States from Afghanistan.
And that's exactly what you're seeing.
Just hours before I came into the studio today,
I saw a video of one of the C-130s
taking off from the airport and two people.
I mean the plane must have been a 1,000 feet
above the ground.
I saw at least two people falling to their death
who had been clinging onto the wheels or something.
There were more people as it was taking off.
I think some people slipped down and decided not to die.
And the other two thought they could stay on there.
And that shows you what people are feeling
about the Taliban taking over everything.
I mean, the Taliban might not be
as great as the north Vietnamese army,
but possibly the Afghanistan military
that we help build is not as good as the Taliban.
I think that's probably really where the truth lies.
There's some something there.
The fact that it just toppled so immediately
is unbelievable.
And in such stark contrast to the dollar spent
and the soldiers deployed or two decades.
But not shocking.
Like if you've read anything I brought in this book,
C.J. Chivers wrote "The Fighters."
He's a Pulitzer prize winning reporter
for the New York Times,
the best war reporter, possibly of his generation,
Iraq War veteran of the first Iraq war,
and then spent a lot of time in combat zones,
and is just a master work of battlefield nonfiction.
And if you read that you can't,
but think this is exactly what was going to happen.
And also that we should be out.
So as opposed to, like,
for me personally, my feeling on this
is when 9/11 happened I was all
for the US to go in and get the Taliban out,
'cause obviously we know Taliban gave safe Harbor
to Bin Laden and Al-Qaeda,
and the Taliban are zealots
that were murdering gay people and women
and exacerbating them in soccer stadiums.
They blew up the Buddhist statues.
They were anti intellectual, anti human rights
and pro Sharia law.
And so, it would be good to get rid of them
is what I thought,
and I still think that that was the right move.
I didn't anticipate 20 years of war and occupation.
I mean, basically trying to repeat
what the Soviet union failed to do.
It just doesn't make any sense.
And listen, if what you built with 20 years
and $2.26 trillion topples in a month,
then maybe it wasn't the right thing to do.
And if you look at it from the perspective
of the guys who are the war fighters,
the guys in the US military,
as horrible as this pretends to be
for women across Afghanistan and all sorts of people,
but basically intellectuals and women
and LBGTQ and Afghanistan,
as awful as this could become for them.
It will become.
Almost certainly will become, is that like,
should we be they're bolstering,
stapling together this hollow a structure
that can get blow over as soon as we're not there.
I mean, is that what we should be doing?
Is that what we should be asking
our children and brothers and sisters to die for?
I mean, it's an open question.
If you read this book, you will think, no,
because if you're not wanted there,
which we weren't wanted there
by a large swath of the population,
then it's not going to work.
And there's argument to be made
because we were there,
the Taliban is more tolerated, not less tolerated.
Now the Taliban has to run the country
and there's gonna be bloodshed.
It's horrible, but at the same time,
it's like, who should be doing that work?
And that's what we're gonna find out
what's gonna happen.
That's not to downplay it, I'm not downplaying it.
There's a great episode on the daily
from one woman's perspective,
what she's going through in this process,
it's very moving.
It's horrible, but that's my thoughts on it.
It's amazing how fast it's happened.
And I was seeing just today,
the media landscape there has already shifted.
People that own storefronts
are taking down posters of women
and they've removed music from the airwaves
and the news channels are already reorienting
their reporting to ensure
that they're not offending Taliban sensibilities.
Like it's unbelievable that it feels almost overnight.
And I think when it comes to judging
or addressing the immediate decisions,
pulling out, not pulling out,
how quickly did we get there to evacuate people?
What could we have done differently?
All of that really seems feudal.
What we really need to do is telescope up
and evaluate the arrogance of imperialism
and its totality, right?
And this sensibility of like,
we're the saviors, we're here to help,
and we're gonna impose military force
and that's gonna transform your country
into a democratic utopia.
I mean, how many times does that experiment have to fail
and how many lives have to be lost
and how much money has to be spent
before we get the message that this is not
our problem to solve.
It's not our sensibility to impose
on such a foreign country to begin with.
I don't know.
I agree with you.
I mean, I think the question is what happened?
Afghanistan in the 70s was the jewel
of the backpacker trail.
When the lonely planet guides were first coming out,
the very first guide, Kabul is like,
they loved Kabul and they spent a lot of time in Afghanistan
and travelers were there all the time in the 70s.
It wasn't far from India, India and Kabul, Afghanistan.
Where Cold War started, Soviet started encroaching
and then we propped up the Taliban
to compete with the Soviets.
We didn't prop up the Taliban.
So we definitely got weapons and funds to different,
I guess, I don't know if it's tribes,
but different factions of this kind of.
Well, it's progenitor of the Taliban.
Well, what ends up happening,
I think if Charlie Wilson's war is this movie
that we both love Mike Nichols movie,
Aaron Sorkin wrote the screenplay
and it talks about this whole Soviet era.
And I think what happens after
they routed the Soviets and came out
there's that scene at the end,
where like Charlie Wilson is trying to get more funding
to get social services back going in Afghanistan.
And, basically they didn't wanna fund that,
nobody wanted to fund that then.
And so what ends up happening in that vacuum,
I think you had forces from Iran
and elsewhere coming in with money
and that's when the kind of the more Sharia law, islamist.
I'm not 100% sure,
but that's what I think is what happened,
and that's when that started to take place in the 80s.
There's an interesting perspective
that was shared today by a Dean and Ayesha Sherzai,
friends of the pod,
neurologists who actually met in Afghanistan.
They were both there during their younger years.
That's in contrast to this idea
that our occupation was this paper tiger
and it was all in futility
and look out quickly it disintegrated.
And their perspective is like, listen,
you know, yes, that's true.
But at the same time,
a lot was done to empower women,
support women's rights and create two generations
or a generation and a half of women
who are in a very different place
as a result of that influence.
And now, us evacuating the area
and the intrusion of the Taliban
and the overtaking puts an end to that.
And not only puts an end to that kind of movement,
but also of course, imperils the very lives of these people.
No doubt about it.
I agree with that too.
A lot of people are gonna get executed.
It seems that way.
Christiane Amanpour on CNN, who I love,
was interviewing a spokesman for the Taliban
who happened to be in Qatar.
Why is the spokesman for the Taliban in Qatar?
Like what is going on?
Like who is funding this operation?
And that person who was saying
that we've put out word, there will be no reprisals.
We will not X, Y, and Z.
No one's gonna get assassinated,
no reason to be afraid, come to work.
But there's also been reports already
of summary executions of soldiers
that were in the Afghan military, some civil servants.
So that report, happened she confronted him with that,
there's a five or six minute clip
that I've got here that was on her Twitter
that we could put up there.
So, it remains to be seen.
It doesn't seem like it's gonna be good,
in that sense, but like,
what are you supposed to do?
Like what are the choices?
I remember when Obama was running for president
and he was like, we're gonna get out of the wars.
And he didn't get out of Afghanistan
probably cause he didn't want this thing happening.
But, at some point you have to either decide,
okay, we're here for 100 years
or you pull out like eventually.
I don't know the answer to that,
but more will be revealed soon.
Shall we pivot?
Pivot to another.
This was gonna be the big story
for like an hour and a half into the podcast.
It was supposed to all be about
what we're going to talk about next.
But you know, this is how this goes, right?
This is what happens.
The climate change conversation.
Yes.
No wonder Greta is so pissed off.
No wonder Gretta is so pissed off.
Climate change gets real.
So we're bringing this up because the IPCC,
the International Panel on Climate Change released
its six report on climate change in land.
It came out last week.
It is the culmination of 500 plus authors,
I believe, with 14,000 papers cited.
And it's this really robust synopsis
essentially of where we're at with climate change
and it aint good.
Essentially what it says is that by 2030,
we're gonna be at 1.5 degrees warmer
than what would be natural
without human influence
and the release of carbon dioxide
and other greenhouse gases in the atmosphere.
And no matter what we do between now and 2050,
we will not be able to stop that rise to 1.5.
Right now we're at one or 1.1.
I think we're at 1.1.
Yeah, 20250, it should be in the next 30 years.
No matter what we do for the next 30 years
we're gonna see this rise,
and there's gonna be obviously repercussions of that,
that are unavoidable at this point.
That's if we completely shut.
If we just said, and this came out in the daily podcast
that came out yesterday, today on this.
Two days ago.
Two days ago,
basically saying like,
if we just flick the switch on carbon emissions today
and went to zero immediately,
we'd still have 30 years.
Of rise to 1.5.
But there's this window where we can take action.
Because if we don't, if we do nothing,
if we keep it as it is now, it won't be 1.5.
It'll be two or three or four perhaps.
And each little chunk means more fires,
more flooding, more potential crop failures
and geopolitical instability.
And irreversible no matter what we do
is ongoing ocean acidification,
ice cap melting, rising seas.
We've just experienced,
I think July was the hottest month on record
as long as they've been recording this stuff.
Fires, the floods in Germany,
all these things that we're seeing.
So the report is coming out
in the midst of an experiential experience,
can I say that?
Where we're all kind of having a tactile relationship
with climate change in a way that does feel unprecedented,
like it does feel like a tipping point.
There's droughts here,
there's fires in Turkey,
there's fires all over, there's heat wave,
there's that crazy melt in Greenland.
So yes, everyone's feeling.
And I think that what's a little bit different
about this IPCC Report
is that it's so irrefutable
and it's so vetted with so many authors
and so many papers cited
that it becomes just absolutely undeniable
that this is happening right now
and yet, and the Daily Podcast pointed this out as well,
there is this sense among the public,
okay, you know, you're sounding the alarm again.
You already sounded it.
It's sort of a cry wolf thing.
Like we've heard this and there's a numbing.
I think that happens with people
and a disconnect between good intentions.
I think most people don't want these things to happen.
And if they were given an opportunity
or an on-ramp to participate in meaningful change,
they would take it,
but there's a lack of agency or a lack of education,
understanding an opportunity
to get involved in something that would be helpful.
And I think that creates a sort of paralysis
among most people.
It's like, okay, well, what do you want me to do?
And meanwhile, I'm gonna go to work and live my life.
Or you post something,
you think you're helping and really.
Or some of the things that
we're diluted into thinking are helpful
are actually like placebos or pacifiers.
Aussie actor, filmmaker, Damon Gameau,
I think is his name.
Damon Gameau.
Damon Gameau, I love Damon's work.
Damon has a great, I call it a rant,
but he's kinda more calm than that.
And he kind of is imploring people to find their agency
because there is this window of time
that we can fix things.
And what's cool about this report
is there is kind of like also a how to
to keep things down.
One is sustainable land management, reforestation,
regeneration and soil preservation,
alternatives to animal agriculture, wind,
aquaculture, kelp farming, that kind of stuff.
Create more carbon sink,
so we can pull carbon out of the atmosphere
and then have a more sustainable future.
But also, one thing that I read in this report
was economic stratification is really bad for climate.
If there was less poverty
and those extremes were a little bit closer together,
we have a better chance of getting
under that three degree, two degree marker.
And this is all based on computer models.
So if you haven't read up on this,
basically what happens is we have more data than ever.
The data started to kind of get accumulated in 1961.
Apparently that's like the big time
when it started happening.
Now there's more Bowie's
out there collecting water temperature,
there's more weather models
and computer models and better computers.
And so what they do
is they feed this data into one computer model
to a computer model that says,
okay, what's gonna happen?
Extrapolate out 10, 20, 30 years from now
and then they take that same model,
but they feed it basically the old numbers,
the numbers without human intervention,
without the greenhouse gases being emitted
and what would have been the natural climate
in that same period of time.
And that's how you get this stuff.
And so it's not an exact science,
but it's kind of like,
what's likely, what's extremely likely, what's most likely?
And those models and those algorithms
are just getting better and better and better
at figuring all of this stuff out.
It made me think of Elizabeth Kolbert book,
"Sixth Extinction."
She has another book out now
it's more directly related to climate change.
And I brought it in here,
but she talks about how humans transcended evolution.
As soon as we painted like the wooly mammoth
on the cave walls,
as soon as we created a way of communicating,
that was not verbal,
that was the beginning of us transcending evolution.
By that she means beyond the control of nature.
Now we can dictate our own lives
no matter what nature throws at you.
Not exactly that,
but like basically obviously nature is still king,
but you can innovate around it
and still nurture your lives and communities and villages
and it's this whole entire agricultural based societies.
And that requires a certain number of genius
and certain manner of genius,
but you can't separate genius and madness.
And if you're gonna have genius,
you're going to have madness.
And so we have madness, right?
We have like the madman on your airplane ride,
the mass shooter, the Taliban zealots,
there's madness kind of within our genius.
And part of the madness is what do we do?
It's paralysis,
it's like we have this pandemic
and we didn't do anything about it for months,
because we are like in some ways
the frog in the boiling water,
we don't believe it until it's there.
And maybe there was a little bit of that in Afghanistan too.
And we see it with climate change now,
the pandemic certainly saw it
in a more compressed nature
and that's happening with climate change right now.
What to do is a great question,
what do you do?
Yeah, I mean, I think what to do,
answering that question begins
with going back to the sixth extinction
and the thesis of that book,
which is that the minute humans created
a dualistic relationship with the planet
through innovation and genius and madness,
it created this sensibility that there is us
and there is the planet.
We are who we are,
and this is nature outside of us.
And I think that mindset is at the core
of everything that we've created and destroyed.
So Paul Hawkin to piggyback on what you just mentioned,
came on the podcast last week,
he's got this beautiful new book called
"Regeneration: Ending the Climate Crisis in One Generation,"
it's an incredible solution-based book.
And he came on the day that the IPCC report came out
and irrespective of the kind of doomsday dystopia
that that picture paints,
he still maintains quite an optimistic disposition
in that the solutions to this problem
are available to us now.
And this book kind of goes through all of them;
energy, land food, et cetera,
all of the different ways.
It's sort of a follow-up to draw down,
but it has a very kind of spiritual holistic approach.
It's less about like,
oh, here's a company doing something interesting
in like growing seaweed underwater,
it's more macro in terms of systems.
And I think the sensibility or the intention behind it
is to get us into a mindset of non-dualism
in our relationship with the planet,
like short of having a spiritual reconciliation,
where we understand that we don't live outside of nature,
and we're not part of nature,
we actually are nature.
And we move towards
a regenerative symbiotic relationship with the planet,
until we're able to do that,
we're not gonna be able to solve these problems.
Like you can hang your hat on
like, oh, we should do wind power and that's great.
But what we really need
is a collective consciousness upgrade
in terms of how we're thinking about this problem
and approaching it.
And he's a gift, the book comes out.
I think the podcast is coming out
in mid-September or something like that.
So it was a little bit of a wait before that happens
and you can pre-order
and I highly suggest everybody pre-order his book.
I think it's gonna be a big deal when it comes out.
But I think what's so kind of amazing
and frustrating at the same time about all of this,
and this comes up in The Daily Podcast
is that we have all these solutions right now.
It's really a function of will,
and most of the will being political will.
Like imagine a situation in which
we appointed like a global dictator
or some kind of global star chamber
that could supersede the decision of any president.
Who just said,
here's like you have one month
before you have to stop producing cars
that work on traditional engines.
And you guys over there,
you have six weeks before no more fracking.
We don't have that role, it doesn't work.
And so we're trying to turn around
these Titanic sized systems
that have so much history and momentum behind them
on a ticking time bomb schedule
and I despair of our ability to do that.
So I think you nailed it.
We can't turn them around.
They have to turn themselves around.
And so that that's happening with shareholder activism,
where people are actually going into these companies,
buying in and hitting shareholder meetings,
it's happening with lobbying of governments
because governments do spend a lot of money
and subsidize X, Y, and Z,
and can help in that regard,
all of that takes agitation from the outside.
It puts pressure to create the political will.
The question is, is it enough pressure?
But the institution has to self govern itself.
It has to accept this is science
and if we wanna be in business,
we have to do X, Y, and Z.
If we wanna continue to function, it's happening,
Ford's putting out electric,
that stuff is happening.
Now electric vehicles is also one of the drivers,
correct me if I'm wrong of this,
like desire to mine the bottom of the ocean.
So it's like the problem
which gets us back to Kolbert is like,
beware of the unintended consequences of good intentions,
like all of these fixes,
what is that going to engender?
Well, that goes back to dualistic,
binary thinnking, right?
Instead of holistic systems thinking,
and that's what regeneration is all about.
It's like these systems are incredibly complex,
no matter how well-intentioned you are
about like this being a solution,
there are all these downstream implications
of whatever decision that you make,
whatever technological innovation that you push forward,
that you can't necessarily foresee.
And so truly the only real solution
is to live symbiotically in nature,
in accordance with the rhythms of the planet.
And that requires us to develop a new appreciation
for indigenous wisdom
and how millennia of human,
not millennia, but however far back humanity goes
where people were so in touch
with their natural environments,
that they understood how to live in a manner
that allowed them to survive and thrive
while also tending to the greater wellbeing
of the macro sphere.
And so can we do that?
Is it possible in our technology first age
to pivot society back to that level of engrossed,
rich relationship with the natural environment
that supports us?
Or are we just gonna punt and go to Mars?
We'll hang our hat on like,
well, we've always figured out a way
to innovate our way out of this.
And so we'll do it again.
That's one line of thinking,
I don't buy that
because that's not being a steward
and that's not the type of thinking
that you're talking about
that Paul Hawken is promoting,
a circular more kind of holistic way.
We will see, but I think watch Damon's great rant
because Damon is asking us to find our agency.
He's asking us to find our agency,
which is why we're talking about it.
We're talking about it
so that everyone starts talking about it,
amongst each other at work, wherever,
we need to talk about it,
'cause it's exactly what Gretta
has been saying for about three years now.
She's been saying the same stuff.
She must think that like,
who does she live with?
I mean, she's been saying exactly,
what's in this report for three years,
if I'm not wrong.
But it begins with changing ourselves
to bring it down to as a Buddhist perspective.
Like you can't change the world
until you inhabit the sensibility that
you're living your life in accordance
with those rhythms yourself,
like that puts you in a position
to create a ripple effect out.
I mean, there has been less,
this is not to say there hasn't been examples
in human history where external fixes have worked.
I mean, it worked in World War II,
but like that there was
a lot of self-preservation involved in that
because not the not Nazi Germany
was invading other countries.
And now we're asking
and the daily podcast points this out as well.
Like we're asking people to self sacrifice
for the betterment of a future generation
to be communitarian in our choices.
And so that's asking a lot of people to do.
We've seen people do it in the past.
Yes, their backs were up against the wall,
Nazis, et cetera.
This is a little bit different.
But in an era where, we don't have a draft
and people are not acclimated to any kind of civil service,
are we able to kind of cohere around this idea.
And when you look at,
all you have to do is open up Twitter
and see how we can't even agree
on a shared reality to think that's a moonshot.
It is discouraging.
And you looking at Afghanistan
as an allegory for the failure of an external fix,
how you can't fix something from the outside,
you can't kill a dark thing.
From the outside, that kind of thing
won't be sustainable.
It may work for 20 years going to remission,
but it's gonna come back
unless you're always there with your thumb on it.
And so now we're talking about this type of thing,
an external fix,
can we adjust or do we have to all adjust?
At the same time, like come together and all adjust.
We've we've done that.
The pandemic is also a lesson
that we can do some things pretty quickly.
It hasn't worked 100%, we've had our problems,
We still have Delta, blah, blah, blah.
But we did get a vaccine.
There's less people getting hurt now
in the city that we're living in
are getting sick now than there were before,
it has worked to some degree.
I look at it through like an addiction model.
Imagine, we're all addicts to our lifestyles
and the conveniences to which we orient our lives
and we need to hit a bottom with this.
So the elevator's going down,
how far down does it have to go before we go
holy shit, I need to change.
How much more pain does the earth have to suffer?
How many cities are gonna have to be under water?
Can you ever imagine yourself in the city underwater?
It's like denial.
Well, I'm good.
It's cool.
Like, look, we did these other good things,
we'll figure this out,
it's very similar in that regard
and our relationship to it
because we're so terrified of having to let go
of the things that we've become accustomed to.
There was a certain amount of self-preservation
involved in the lifestyle adjustment with the pandemic.
But this is like,
you can't really imagine yourself in the city
that's inundated by floods.
One of the things in this report is
that these tidal floods that used to happen once a year,
maybe are gonna happen four times a year
or something like that.
Like all these, the rainfall gets worse,
everything gets worse.
The droughts become more frequent and common.
And we're seeing that, right?
We're seeing that in our lifetime.
I don't know, man, but just to like end this
with a couple things that we actually can do
in our lives that are practical.
Here's an idea, it has to do with laundry
and washing your dishes.
Do you do your own laundry, Rich?
Sometimes I do.
But I'm now gonna do it differently
than I have historically done it
by virtue of revisionist history,
Malcolm Gladwell's latest episode
called "Laundry Done Right"
where he digs deep on laundry, which sounds weird.
And of course has a revisionist take
on how to do it correctly.
So I will freely admit that my approach to laundry
in terms of trying to be a good ecological steward
has been to make sure that I purchase
the eco-friendly soap that's made with natural ingredients,
trying to limit the number of loads that I do.
But what I have not done
has been to pay attention to water temperature.
And what this podcast explains,
it's kind of fascinating,
is that all of our focus
on the chemistry of our soap is misplaced
when the focus should be placed upon water temperature,
because I don't know what the stats,
I'd have to listen to it again.
Maybe, you know offhand,
because I think he listened to it more recently.
But most of the kind of ecological damage
is a result of using a warm and hot water.
It's something like 70% of energy can be saved.
So it's about carbon,
it's about greenhouse gas emissions.
So you save 70% of emissions
if it's warm water versus cold
and 90% of it's hot water versus cold.
So rather than getting the eco-friendly soap,
we should be looking at the chemistry
that goes into creating a detergent
that allows you to effectively wash your clothes
in cold water.
Because most detergents,
they end up washing better in warm water.
Warm, especially with the lights,
I mean, the whites and the lights and stuff like that,
which I've done many times.
And, getting soap that causes too much suds
because it uses more water
because the cycle won't stop
until all the suds are gone
and you're gonna be using like ridiculous amounts of water
and the amount of energy that it takes to heat that water
is really where the environmental damage is taking place.
So if you had a polymer that would allow you
to wash your clothes in cold water with very little suds,
that's kind of like the holy grail.
So Malcolm goes and visits like
this chemical engineer at Procter and Gamble
and he just falls in love with corporate America.
Well, specifically with the engineers
at Procter and Gamble.
But it was interesting,
and it has changed how I think about this.
And of course, the close cousin to laundry,
which is detergent, or dishwashing detergent.
Similarly where, you know, I often,
I generally like rinse my dishes
before I put them in the dishwasher.
And apparently at least
with respect to the latest dishwashers,
you don't need to do that.
And most of the ecological damage,
because the new dishwashers are so eco efficient and capable
that you shouldn't rinse your dishes beforehand,
and you would save a tremendous amount of water.
They say that if you have eight dishes or more,
run the dishwasher every night,
and that saves more water and energy
than if you had the hot water on for two minutes.
And so, which I would never do either,
but I will say this,
I am a cold water clothes washer.
I've been a cold water launder for at least 10 years.
So this is the thing that comes up in the podcast.
They're like, they make this decision
that if you're gonna hire somebody,
the first question,
maybe the only question you need to ask them
is how they do their laundry.
If they say they're a cold water person
you hire them immediately.
Because the idea is like,
he actually hires his friends firm
to go and do like market research
into who are these cold water washers.
And they all ended up having
like incredible detail oriented recall
on what models they buy
and why they're doing everything.
And I am like, not that cold water washer.
I'm not the guy that's like super hyper detail oriented
about every deep thing they do.
I'm more of an intuitive, cold water washer.
You just knew you just like,
I feel like cold water is the way to go.
I do the right thing intuitively most of the time.
Will April agree with that?
I think so.
I think we just found the quote for the podcast.
I am an intuitive person.
Wait, say it again.
I do the right thing intuitively most of the time.
I think that's how you should introduce yourself.
Well, they said, who are these super humans
that know all this stuff?
And I'm like, I'm not that I'm not that cold water washer,
but I am a cold water washer.
I also like how the episode is like,
what's cool about it to me is he's kind of,
even though it's funny to hear him going
to Procter and Gamble
and talk up the people who make Tide.
Apparently, Tide is the best detergent to use in cold water
'cause it's engineered to do it.
It's the cutting edge of science
in terms of washing dishes.
He backs it up because
like apparently Procter and Gamble's whole campus
is wind powered.
There they are doing the right.
This is an example of an organization that
is doing what we're suggesting.
And I think what's cool about it
is that it's so easy
to just vilify these gigantic conglomerates,
when in truth,
reality is more nuanced and complicated than that.
And we have to rebuild trust institutions,
like from both sides.
And it's not just, right-wing,
who's been going after institutions like the news media.
It's also people on the left doing it,
especially in the health and wellness
and the lifestyle industry.
And there is a time now to rebuild trust institutions.
And it feels super weird for me to say it
since I felt like a rebel most of my life,
especially from my teenage years
till I was in my 30s until just recently, really?
And now I'm the guy like,
yes, we need to have more trust in our institutions,
which is just so it doesn't seem
like even sit right for me to say it, but it is true.
I do believe that.
And this is an example,
this episode kind of shows you why that's true.
Yeah, and I think.
To really unpack these counterintuitive narratives
in the sense that listen,
if you're the proprietor
of an all natural laundry detergent
that creates a lot of suds,
I'm sure you're very proud of your product
and none too pleased to find out
that actually your goal being to save the planet,
you're working across purposes with that.
You know, that's disturbing to find out.
And at the same time to understand
that these big corporate players
might be onto something worthy of exploration
because our instinct is we wanna celebrate the little guy
or person who's all natural is by necessity good.
And it doesn't always operate that way.
You see the same thing in philanthropy,
like we are emotional beings
and we wanna donate to the causes
that we feel strongly about.
And yet from a kind of an effective altruism perspective,
that's not necessarily the best use of your money.
You could save more lives
if you just gave it to a company that makes malaria tents,
as opposed to, some organization
that's trying to feed underprivileged kids
in a food desert, urban environment,
but our emotions come into play
and we wanna believe certain things
and I think that complicates all of that.
That's one reason this is important
is just to underline is that he says
in his podcast episode,
25 billion loads of laundry are done every year
in the United States and Canada.
And so these small decisions actually do extrapolate
and create quite a big debt.
So if everybody just started only washing with cold water,
that would be huge.
Or if Proctor and Gamble,
or whoever comes up with the ultimate laundry detergent
that allows you to clean your clothes effectively
without heating the water at all,
like that makes a huge difference.
Didn't Adrian Grenier have though
a counterpoint to detergent pods.
Yeah, he did.
I did a podcast interview with him a while ago,
it hasn't gone up yet,
kind of actor environmentalist for a long time.
He put up a video on Instagram recently
about detergent pods
and I talked about it with him on the podcast.
Basically, those pods that are wrapped
in a very thin layer of plastic
are sold on the premise that you just put them in
and that wrapping completely dissolves
and allows you to wash your clothes
and it cuts down on container costs, et cetera.
But in truth, and I haven't vetted this
so I don't know whether this is true,
but from what I understand what he said,
and some other experts that he was interviewing
or speaking to about this,
that plastic becomes invisible and porous,
but it actually doesn't dissolve.
It becomes like this imperceptible,
gooey gel that just never,
ever goes away and ends up of course,
seeping into our waterways and ultimately into our seas.
And no doubt, you know, contributing to all manner of ills,
whether we're aware of them or not at this point.
So no detergent pods.
Well, that could end soon,
cause Marcus Ericsson at Five Gyres
was telling me that he's actually
in touch with the people at plastic companies
that are looking at a new polymer
that will make plastic itself,
just all plastic that's wrapped up
could become biodegradable at some point.
And if that is true and that does happen
and that's maybe not in the too distant future,
there's actually some tests happening right now,
then that could be a replacement for it.
We gotta get rid of plastic.
I know.
That's our attempt to innovate out of this mess.
All right.
Well, let's take a quick break
and pivot to listener questions, shall we?
Let's do it.
Presto we're back
and we materialized a new human.
What's up, Ted?
How are you, man?
Good to have you here.
Ted McDonald is in the house.
He's gonna contribute
to answering these listener questions.
Ted is a longtime friend of both Adam and I,
but for separate reasons like it's weird,
like we've known each other.
I mean, I've known you for like 20 years.
Solid 20 years.
And you know, Adam,
through a completely different set of circumstances
for an equal amount of time.
Exactly.
Which is wild.
You guys know each other through LA Yoga.
That's right.
LA yoga, when I was helping to start that publication,
we got in contact 'cause he was doing an adventure yoga,
which he still does,
adventure yoga retreats
and was already a yoga stalwart in the community.
How about you guys?
Through the yoga community in LA,
through Maha Yoga originally, I think.
We sed to go do yoga together.
So Ted is not only a very accomplished Yogi
and yoga teacher, you're a yoga studio owner.
You're a yoga practitioner.
You're an adventure athlete
and endurance athlete and iron man, a coach.
What else?
You do lots of stuff.
A dad.
Kindergarten parent as of Wednesday,
but lead groups around the world.
I think that's one of the big things,
the retreats that have been a huge asset
and bright point in my life, I would say.
And he joins the yoga kind of left,
I guess that'd be left-brain,
like the yoga world
with the high performance athlete world
in his own life, but also working that way
with different athletes and clients.
Well, yeah.
And I think, you know, interestingly enough,
I ran my first marathon
and took my first yoga teacher training with Max Strom.
Do you remember Sour Powers?
Yeah, and I remember Max, for sure.
Sour Powers and TS Little way back 20 plus years ago.
At the same time I did my first marathon.
Never thought I would ever do a marathon
and sorta got convinced.
I always say I got suckered into doing my first marathon
and just fell in love.
I fell in love with training.
I fell in love with racing.
I fell in love with the experience
and the people and the energy and the vibe
and it was just so great.
I'll never forget crossing that finish line and in tears
because I, first of all,
wasn't even believing that I could actually do it.
But then I thought,
wow, if I could do this six weeks prior
was not part of my sphere of consciousness.
Now, what else is there that I don't know that I can do?
And that started this whole like,
well, I'll try a triathlon
and then I'll just start adventure racing
and then I'll just keep going,
and it was the whole thing.
At the same time, the yoga for me
was always the glue that kind of kept it together.
There you go.
It's cool, it's really cool.
And he left something off his resume.
What's that?
He coached me to the fourth place finish
in the Catalina run experience.
You were coaching Adam.
I didn't even know that.
I think I might've told you.
You did.
I don't know, I don't remember hearing that,
but that's cool.
You fired me.
You got fired right.
Now you're with the envelope guy, right?
Like what happened?
I don't know, you know, things change.
We grow out of these relationships,
but I never grew out of my relationship with Ted.
We haven't seen each other in a long time,
but we were both at the same wedding in Telluride.
It was super nice to reconnect
and meet your family and all of that.
And I invited you to come by the studio.
Adam was like, he should join for the listener questions.
We have questions that are right in your wheelhouse.
So why not?
Why not?
I love it, I appreciate it.
Go back to Ben and Jerry's.
There's a whaling boat with your name on it,
headed to Greenland right now.
Yeah, it's true.
I am the ice cream guy on the whaling boat.
Just stay off the laudanum.
All right, our first question is from Nate from Colorado.
Hi Rich.
Hi, Adam.
This is Nate from Colorado.
And first of all, I just wanted to say,
thanks for everything you guys are doing.
Last episode, you guys answered a question
about what doing the work means,
but what I am wondering is what you do
when doing the work becomes stale, stagnant,
or an added stressor to life to try and fit in.
I've been quote unquote, doing the work for a few years now,
having adopted a whole food plant-based diet
and always having a morning routine
that is consisted of some combination
of journaling, meditation and exercise.
But after doing this for several years,
I find the practice becoming stale and unfulfilling,
and it has developed an almost negative connotation for me.
It feels like a chore
and it's sort of become a list of conditions
I need to meet daily in order to feel okay about my day,
as well as feel good about myself mentally.
And at times it feels like it's adding stress to my life
rather than helping me cope with life.
So my question is,
have you guys ever experienced this
and if so, how did you handle it?
And what advice would you offer?
Thanks again, for all you guys do.
It's a constant source
of helpful information and inspiration.
Thanks again.
When self care becomes OCD.
Ted, you wanna tackle this?
Sure, sure.
I think that it's important
to be aware of the present moment.
And I think oftentimes we get into
the rituals that we're doing
and we lose the fact that every single moment
is a frigging miracle
and it's so intense and overwhelming
that I think oftentimes we step aside
and we don't allow that in.
So I just remember on yoga retreats, years ago with Max,
and being in triangle pose and looking out the window
and seeing Zaka lake, I don't know.
Did you ever go to Zaka Lake?
Anyway, just looking out the window
and seeing this beautiful blue sky and these green hills
and then all of a sudden, just weeping.
And I thought, what is that?
Why is that?
And I think I realized
it was just because I was so overcome
by the beauty of the moment.
And I think oftentimes we lose
and I share this a lot on retreats
or different conversations.
It's like, you know, this glass, right.
We can just feel the shape of it
and the immense thought that goes into it,
or, one thing I was thinking is,
when you're journaling, how often do you stop
and take a magnifying glass
and look at the fibers inside the page,
or like Deepak Chopra used to say,
don't just look and go,
oh wow, those flowers, they look so beautiful.
Like stop for a second and feel the immense miracle
that really is the moment.
And I don't know if this happens because,
you know, being someone who had,
who felt like I was gonna lose my life at some point,
and then being a sober guy now
and having that sort of deep sense
of gratitude for the moment,
or if that's something you can develop
as someone who hasn't had an experience like that.
But I really feel like no matter what it is,
no matter where you are, no matter what you look at,
whether it's a person or a thing,
there's this and it's perception.
And they talk about this a lot,
but it's shifting your perception.
So, just one more thought,
which, they talk about astronomers, right?
You need to be happy shoveling the shit
before you can be happy doing the other stuff.
And until you can be happy doing that stuff,
I think it will become monotonous.
So a solution, I would say Nate,
is either to shift your perspective
on what is actually happening,
or maybe take a break.
You know, I think the simple thing
is just to take a break for a moment and live free
and don't be attached to that routine
and have this free experience of doing things
and see what comes up from there.
Should we just get up and leave and let Ted take over?
I think he just solidified his value.
I'm sorry for loafing for all this months.
No beautifully put, I love it.
I think it's about your relationship
to the practices and the rituals.
And what I sense is an extreme level of rigidity
where there's a lot of self-judgment packed
into the doing or the not doing.
There's a referendum on how you feel about yourself
and who you are
that's based upon whether you're adhering
to a very strict set of circumstances.
Yes, of course, that becomes unsustainable.
And I think the solution does lie in holding these things
a little bit more lightly
and anchoring yourself in the moment
and understanding that it's not the ritual per se
or the practice as much as it is your awareness
around the practice
and your ability to be present with these practices
that are the conveyor belt
to the transformation that you're seeking.
So it sounds like you're holding on so tightly
and you've been doing it for so long.
Like I would suggest that if you've been meditating
for this amount of time and the result is frustration,
there's something broken in this practice altogether,
because that's not the intended result
that we're looking for here.
So what exactly are you doing?
What is your relationship to that doing?
And, if you're coming out of it resentful in burden,
then something is fundamentally wrong.
So it's about letting go of the attachment
or the meaning that you're attaching
to the results of this practice
that's causing you to self-flagellate
and letting go of it all together.
And I suspect that if you stopped doing these things
and maybe do nothing,
you'll have an uncomfortable period where you're like,
well, I'm supposed to be doing this thing.
So my life's not gonna move in the right direction
until I go back to doing that thing.
That's what you need to examine here.
And if you are gonna journal journal about that.
And I'll just add one more thought
that came into my head is,
spent listening to Rom Doss, right.
And Rom Doss, he said,
all of these different techniques
are ultimately supposed to go away
and you're just supposed to be living in the moment.
And I think it's a little different
if you're analyzing your journaling
and your thought thinking and your drinking water
and you're having your vitamins
and you're doing all that stuff.
I think there's some stuff that you wanna do
because that's your medicine.
But I also think there are certain things like you're saying
that you get stuck in,
and I think at some point,
some of those need to just go away
and then you just live.
I feel like it's upside down.
Like the priority is on like the practice
as if the practice itself is the result,
as opposed to what you're really trying to do
is become more connected.
Well, it's mindfulness, right?
You're trying to take mindfulness away from the mat
away from rigidity and into the world,
like behold the glass.
There is no glass.
It's like, you know, you wanna take that,
like you can't live your life that way,
but you can find moments.
And so like those mindfulness moments,
maybe that's, it mindfulness moments.
Because if the practice is drained of its beauty,
then you're missing the whole point altogether.
Well, he probably feels that he is missing it
that's why he's asking the question.
But also, I mean, I don't think it's that unnatural
to hit a plateau, is it?
Obviously that's like you're
on the precipice of a breakthrough.
Like something is trying to be communicated to you
that could take you to a higher plane.
So focus the mindfulness and the journaling
on what that block is
and the frustration that you're having
and I think there's this golden opportunity
for you to kind of ascend to the next level
in your awareness.
The resistance is like overcoming that,
it's like going to be beautiful.
All right, let's move on to the Bay Area.
Aloha, Rich and Adam.
It's Heidi here from Nor Cal.
I have a question for you about finding the right coach.
Next year, I'm making the leap from Ironman distance
to Ultraman, and I've done multi-day events,
triathlons, but nothing compared to Ultraman yet.
So I'm really excited and I've trained off and on
for the past 10 years with a triathlon team,
taking on some one-on-one coaching
before the pandemic has closed everything.
So anyway, this year my team is back
and they are training together.
And now I'm thinking about my own coaching situation.
And my question is what are the best questions interview
the coach for a good fit?
I think most coaches,
including myself as nutritionists,
take an intro screening call.
I'm interested in data,
but it's not the only thing that drives me.
And also I managed bipolar type one,
and it's connected to my why.
So I'm inspired by Courtney Dauwalter
not having a coach.
I plan out my myself coaching by one week at a time
it's worked out well,
but I think I could benefit from having
an objective fluid structure feedback
and yeah, we'll see where it goes.
Thank you guys, both.
Thank you, Heidi.
This question has Ted's name written all over
so I'm gonna it defer to Ted.
But I will say this one thing.
When interviewing a prospective new coach,
the only question you need to ask this coach is
what are your laundry habits?
Do you wash in cold water?
That's it.
If not you're out.
I was wondering about the dryer
because we hang our clothes as often as we can.
There you go, then.
Is that better?
Of, course.
Is it better than hot water in the wash?
Like, should I cold water?
You still should cold water.
Opting out of the dryer and washing with hot water
does not absolve you.
Well, I'm glad that's what I got up Tide
because now I've got this whole,
I'm gonna talk to DK about it.
I think there's all these old school brands
that I'd like us to consider for ads.
It's broken and I have been talking about.
Oreos are vegan.
Come on, Oreos.
The under reported nutritional benefits
of pre packaged hostess products.
All right, Ted coaching.
Yes, Heidi.
I would say that,
I mean, I don't know,
you know, for me as a coach,
one of the first things that I,
if I'm gonna hire a coach,
so I've hired coaches for different events,
specific events.
I train myself pretty well,
but then if I'm doing like Ironman, I had a coach.
Kilimanjaro, I put together a team for that
just because I felt like I wanted to make sure
I had the right body stuff
and nutrition stuff and supplement stuff
and training and all that sort of thing.
I, as a coach, and also as an athlete,
I would like to know that someone
that I feel like someone can get me there.
I mean, it's as simple as that.
Can they get me there?
That's the first thing.
Is there a vibe, right?
Because you're gonna be spending some time with them,
there's gonna be conversations,
they're gonna be back and forth, email texts, workouts.
Do they understand you?
Do they not understand you?
I personally like someone who has had some experience,
I don't know, like they don't necessarily need
to have done the ultra man,
but some sort of.
Have they coached other athletes who have done that race?
Either that, or do they understand
what it's gonna take to get through it?
Meaning have they suffered a certain amount?
Do they understand what it's going
to take to recover from one day to the next right?
Cause it's a stage race
versus a 24 or 48 hour non-stop race.
So I think those kinds of questions,
but I think ultimately have had some experience?
Is the vibe there for you?
And do you think that they can actually get you there?
You know, I talked to a guy recently
who tried to climb Everest and didn't make it.
And he said that he thought it was his coach.
So that's either a, passing the buck,
or it's maybe the coach was not right,
maybe there was not the right vibe there.
So I think that it's an important relationship
when you take on a big event like that.
So that's what I would say.
I mean, I think that's all right.
I would agree with all of that on the vibe piece.
I think you need to be clear on what your needs are.
Like, do you need somebody to be
an emotional support for you
or do you just need the workouts?
Do you need feedback and what does that feedback look like?
Do you need emotional feedback?
Do you just need metrics feedback?
Do you like to be left alone?
Do you want somebody to tell you what to eat for breakfast?
Like all of that is gonna be different
depending upon the athlete.
And you wanna make sure
that you're in a good fit with a coach
who can meet the needs that you require,
but it requires clarity on what those needs are,
first of all, so you're not mismatched.
And I that's a good point
because there's so much that goes into,
see, I look at as a coach, you know,
I want someone to be getting body work done.
I want them to be more balanced.
I don't want it to just be metrics and numbers and speed.
It has to have nutrition has to happen properly.
Sleep has to happen properly.
So there is that and life happens.
So in any relationship in any event that we do,
stuff happens, we get sick,
kids go to school or they they're sick.
Is this coach gonna be understanding
of what the kind of gestalt of your life is?
And it depends on how deep it is.
Is it just a simple plan to say,
here's the plan, see you later?
Or is it actually going to be more
of an in-depth relationships?
And do you respond to positive feedback or negative?
Like, do you need somebody to say good job?
Or do you want somebody to say,
Hey, you're really like off the reservation here.
Are you gonna walk if they give you
some negative feedback?
Is that going to be a problem?
All of that is very personal.
And I think with respect to ultraman,
as somebody who's done Ultraman a couple of times,
it's very different from ironman.
So most people that coach iron man athletes
most likely have not coached somebody for ultra man.
Ultra man is completely different, like Ted said,
it's a stage race.
It's fundamentally a cycling race,
more than anything with a couple appendages tagged onto it.
And the way that you train for it
is going to look very different
from the way that you train
for any other kind of triathlon.
You don't need to do any transition work,
you don't need to new brick work,
you don't really need to any kind of tempo
or speed work for the most part,
unless you're already super accomplished and you need,
to sort of hone that razor's edge.
So it depends upon your skill level at the time as well.
So finding somebody who can meet all of those needs,
I mean, it's a tall order, but very doable.
And I'm glad that you're looking for a coach,
'cause I think you should have a coach
for a race like this.
There is this temptation.
I've heard this, not just from you,
but from other people like.
Oh, I heard Courtney Dauwalter
and she's all about intuitive.
And it's like, you got to understand,
like she is, you know, an outlier,
like most people left to their own intuition
to train the way that they feel
are gonna lead themselves down a dark alleyway
and it ain't going to be good.
And she had plenty of coaching along the way.
She has foundation of that course.
Absolutely.
Is it a 10 kilometer open water swim
then like a couple of hundred on the bike.
You're going 90 on the bike the first day
and 171 on the bike the next day.
And then you got a little double marathon.
You got to run in there, but now it's all very doable.
That's hilarious.
That's the dessert.
My advice is to make sure they can do
that whistle without the pinkies in their lips.
I want a coach that can whistle me like that
and then wear a headband at all times on Zoom.
In the proper snorkel mask.
And do they make you wear
a swim mask slash snorkel?
All right, we'll do one more question.
And this one's for me and it's tailored specifically
to Ted since he's here.
And I think it's a question
that I think will be beneficial to a lot of people.
And it's basically just
about how you Ted see the role of yoga
in the context of being an athlete.
Like I often look at yoga
and wish that I had been an avid practitioner
of yoga when I was in my competitive swimming years
and understanding the benefits of that,
not just for kind of strength and balance and agility,
but also restorative and injury prevention.
And of course, the true benefit of it,
which is kind of spiritual awareness.
So how do you think about how yoga fits in
to being an athlete and performance specifically?
And how do you sort of talk about how you recommend yoga
for the kind of every day or weekend warrior athlete?
I recommend yoga
for the every day weekend warrior athletes,
you know, two to three times a week if they could,
but the truth is most people are like once a week,
and that's it.
And I almost see it as if
you were gonna go run once a week.
You could go for a jog once a week
and go slow and go two, three miles or four miles
or five miles once a week
is not really gonna get you to a marathon
if you're doing that.
So yoga, I think is a similar thing.
In my opinion, it is again, like I said earlier,
the glue that brings it all together.
The first class I ever took was Brian Kest,
back in Santa Monica, right?
We used to go up the stairs
and then there'd be like a little chest
and you could just leave whatever money you wanted.
There was like donation-based.
So that day I fell in love with yoga because it was,
as an athlete growing up, playing baseball,
and football and lacrosse back on the east coast.
I started that and I was sore for four days
and I couldn't believe it
and I could barely hold my body up.
And I thought, wow, this is real, first of all.
And it just made me feel so good
and just having stress in life and,
I was at that time.
I dunno how sober I was.
It was maybe a few years, right?
So it was just a sales still stressful.
And it was a big sigh of relief for me.
And every single class that I went to
was a big sigh of relief
and then I started doing more.
So I did that for almost three years, just yoga.
Then I started running,
I thought, oh, I want a little cardio in my life.
So I'm gonna add a couple miles a couple of times a week
and ran two miles and was sore for four days
because I didn't run for almost three years.
Then started to run again
and realized how much the yoga practice actually helped me
just balance out my body.
So from a physical standpoint, in my opinion,
I think that it is absolutely 100% necessary
because from an athletic standpoint,
you're just pounding and pounding and pounding and pounding
and trying to get faster and stronger
and faster and stronger, faster and stronger.
And there's not really a sense.
I mean, now in the last maybe decade,
there's been a lot more attention to recovery,
but in my opinion, yoga is definitely something
that people should be doing on a regular basis.
Now, obviously the word yoga is such a huge umbrella.
So what I would recommend is
one or two classes a week,
that's a little bit more of a flow style
and at least one, or maybe two classes a week, that's yin.
Because sitting in those poses for a really long time
and lengthening your connective tissue,
I think has a huge benefit.
I feel like that's one of the reasons
why I've been able to keep my flexibility,
even though I'll do endurance events still.
So from a physical standpoint,
I think that's a big thing.
I think that, back when I was adventure racing,
2001 through five basically
is kind of my four or five year stint
in adventure races
and anything from two to five hour sprint races
all the way up to 24 to 48 hour races.
And I remember passing team balanced bar
and the guy was cramping up and he was freaking out
because his body was just locked up
and our team practiced yoga.
I mean, we also hydrated
and we thought about all this stuff back then.
And in a way it was sort of like,
oh, well, that hasn't happened to us, thankfully.
Now whether it's the yoga or whether it's nutrition
or whether that guy was having a bad day
or just got over some sickness, we have no idea.
But the point is that I feel like
it balanced out my athletic ability
and continues to this day,
that was 20 years ago, 15 years ago.
My goal ultimately is to continue to do what I love to do
for as long as I possibly can.
And yoga will absolutely 100% be part of that.
And so I don't, to me,
I don't know that I'm gonna be doing 100 milers
or ultimately maybe a half marathon,
trail run when I'm 100 years old or hike,
I don't care if I walk or how I go,
but the idea is to be active.
And I think that the mental aspect and the spiritual,
I think the spiritual aspect is a whole other episode,
but the point is that I think from a mental aspect,
you see yourself a little bit differently.
And I think that the yoga develops that over time,
oftentimes people come as, you know,
they'll come in because,
oh, I have the shoulder thing
or, oh, I have a back thing or whatever it is.
But then over time you started to realize,
oh wow, I feel better
and then you start to perform better outside.
So, we've talked in the past about the BMC guys.
So I used to work with, for about a decade,
I work with a professional cycling team
and it was like pulling teeth
to try to get these guys into yoga.
You would share like videos
and they're trying to get in the poses.
It's like comical.
You go on their training camp and stuff like that.
That's right.
But they're so steeped in their idea
of what professional cycling is supposed to be
that to have them veer a little bit was so challenging.
I think that that's changed in general among athletes.
And I think that's a huge, huge thing.
I think that ultimately it helps us with everything.
It helps us with how we live
and how we operate and how we communicate.
And I think the yoga practice brings a softer side.
It brings the yin to the yang.
And instead of, 100 miles, 200 miles, 900 miles,
it's sort of like,
hey, let's experience this,
let's experience the fiber of our network,
the fibers of our journal
and have that be part of the experience,
not just the numbers
and all of us are not competing as professionals.
So I don't know about other people
and maybe it's different
when you have to meet these certain metrics
and perform at a certain speed, et cetera.
But I think for me
it's a must do for sure,
and two or three times a week,
I would say minimum, right?
I mean, you should just like,
also like just qualify your bonafide days
here a little bit.
I mean, you did Kilimanjaro,
you've done all these adventure races.
How many have you done?
You've done iron mans, right?
So actually I've only done one official Ironman,
I remember.
So my first marathon was in 2000,
then I did the Malibu triathlon,
that was my first ever triathlon.
And then I went immediately to adventure racing
and started with
what used to be the high tech adventure racing series.
I don't know if you remember that.
So I got a couple of people then I thought,
oh wow, If I can get into the elite division,
you know, that would be great.
So we found, I was at a mud run.
This is before tough, modern Spartan.
So we were at the mud run and camp at Camp Pendleton
and the second place woman was right behind me.
First place woman was a bit in front of me,
second place so I just kind of followed her to the showers
and heard her talking about marathons.
And I said, oh, Hey, by the way,
ever done any adventure racing?
And she said,
"oh no, but we were going to try to do this high tech."
I said, "Well, I'm building a team.
We just did this one.
So why don't we start training together?"
She said, "Yeah, I'm moving up to Pasadena."
She became our female
and we started competing
and we did the balance bar 24 hour adventure racing series.
And then we do the Cal Eco Series and it was amazing.
I mean, it's funny because you know,
and this goes a little bit back to Heidi's question two,
which is, there's one thing to do
a workout for an hour to 45 minutes an hour.
It's another thing to do one to three hours.
It's another thing to go three to five or six.
It's another thing to go 10, 11, 12 in a day.
It's another thing to go overnight.
And you mentioned with Courtney
as we're talking about hallucinations, right?
I mean, so it's a whole other experience
when you sort of walk through that looking glass
and that's what happens when you go overnight.
It's obviously not something
it's going to be different thing ultra man,
because you get to actually sleep a little bit.
But anyway, and then I would say that
then Leadville and I eventually I did Ironman
and then Kilimanjaro was a few years ago,
which was amazing.
What did you do at Leadville?
I got frostbit that frost bit,
frost nip from Kilimanjaro.
Not the run, so to be clear,
and the bite just happened.
I think there was the grout.
They did a gravel version also I think.
Is that right?
Maybe I'm wrong.
No Steamboat was the next day.
And then Stefano was pretty high up in Leadville.
But he's now racing gravel, I think if I'm not mistaken,
I don't know.
He was on BMC for years.
But you did a 50 mile run right?
So 50K a few times.
So 100 milers in the future, little kids now
so training is not as ample that time,
but I love seeing what my body can do in a healthy way.
So I have no interest in pounding myself
into the ground sooner than I need to be.
But I do love to experience the unknown in a way.
So I love setting up these experiences.
That's why I said, let's do Otillo in November.
We're gonna be teammates.
I'm gonna be tethered to him and he's gonna run.
I'm gonna try to find a chair with wheels,
not a wheel chair,
more like a lounge chair with wheels.
And I'll be the guy on the water, I'll lead this one,
but we're still only gonna do,
I think we're just doing the 15, whatever the 15.
I don't have time to train.
I'm in the zero to three hours category.
The other thing I'll add to my,
been patting myself on the back here,
but the Inca trail, so the Inca trail was super fun.
So normally it's a four day event
and I was leading a retreat to Peru
and we had about whatever, 17, 20 people
and my friend, who's an ultra guy now.
He said, "Hey man, why don't we run the Inca trail?"
I said, "Why?"
And he goes, "Why not?"
I said, "Oh, good question."
So we talked to Carlos,
my guy that I've been dealing with since 2006,
going down there, he's my travel guide.
And I said, Carlos, come on, man,
we gotta run the Inca trail.
It's 20 miles, isn't it?
Why would you want to do that?
I think it's just 22
and it goes over a 14,000 foot peak
and then down to 11,000,
then over 13,000 foot peak.
So it's not that big of a deal
as far as like a big deal goes,
but no one began one day.
We trotted it and it was kind of run hike
and it was his first thing.
But to do that and then to get,
have you been to Machu Picchu?
Have you been to Machu Picchu?
Oh my gosh.
So there is the sun gate that as soon as you come across
and you see the sun that then you're looking down
onto Machu Picchu
and every single retreat that I've ever led there,
I always walk people up and I have them close their eyes
and then they just open their eyes to see Machu Picchu.
And you get that same kind of awe inspiring feeling
and to have run all of this
over the course of the day and then get there.
We were both just going, oh my God,
we were just in tears from the experience.
So it was a very cool thing.
And the reason I say that is not because,
it was any athletic feat.
I mean, it is a decent athletic feat,
but more so about that's the motivation I think,
is to find these experiences like that,
like running the backbone trail,
or mountain biking, the like different things.
And you've alluded to that on your podcast multiple times,
but it's to find these things
that just push us a little bit more
and to give us an experience
that we wouldn't necessarily have
instead of living in that little box
that we sometimes tend to just fall into.
Will you come back and do a formal coach's corner?
I'd love to, I'd love to.
Beautifully put my friend, thank you.
Thanks for having me, absolutely.
If people wanna connect with you,
where's the best place to direct them?
Do you have any retreats coming up
that you're putting together?
Yeah, I'm in the midst of putting together
a Malibu retreat in November
and then next year I have a few things.
I started doing a little research into Bhutan and Nepal.
I think that I'd like to hike up a little bit
to some Buddhist temples out there.
But as far as connecting,
Teddy MacDonald on all the social media,
Instagram and Facebook and Twitter.
I'm not as active on Twitter.
But I would say that Malibu and then
we'll see what happens next year.
But, again, I just wanna continue
to kind of create the unknown.
And are you looking for coaching clients?
Is your roster full?
No, it's not.
So we got the yoga studio in Malibu
and then we do some online stuff.
Is it open now?
Are you teaching in the studio or is it still?
I am.
So since April, we slowly started coming back
and I thought, oh yay, we're coming back.
We're coming back.
And then all of a sudden,
the Delta variants sort of like put
a little bit of a damper on that,
but people do still come to the studio.
So if you're in Malibu,
then definitely come and check us out.
We have a limited amount of classes,
but we also do online classes.
So if you're looking to get into yoga,
I'm happy to sort of give you a little bit of a thing.
Actually, I started streaming once the pandemic hit,
I started streaming.
Adam did a little piece for the New York Times,
which was great.
But I just, because I felt like back then,
it was really important to start to share
our resources as individuals,
I really felt like that was important.
So I thought if there's anything that I know how to do,
it's help people move through stress.
And it was a really stressful time
so I felt like that was important.
And I kept doing that once a week.
So usually on Mondays, I do a little yoga for athletes.
My friend is the Race Director for the Malibu Half Marathon,
which happens in November.
So we kind of stream two,
my channels and her channel,
and otherwise it's for the members that come and join us.
But I'm happy to have any of your listeners be a guest.
You do a Jackson retreat in the winter.
That's right.
So every year we go to Jackson Hole.
Tony Horton, who's a good buddy of mine,
so he and I lead Ted and Tony's ski yoga trip too.
I laugh because it's like one of the most fun.
Sound like so chest pounding though,
like a little intimidated.
Well, it's funny people like,
I'm a snowboarder or I can't really see.
And Jackson Hole is intense, right?
So there's plenty of things to do
as far as plenty of terrain for beginners, intermediate,
and there's plenty of people who will come on the retreat
and not ski because it's Jackson Hole,
the Grand Tetons are right down the block,
the Yellowstone is around the corner
so it's an amazing place.
So you don't necessarily have to.
And the thing is we do yoga in the morning,
yoga in the evening.
Tony's a little bit more of a chest pounder
where my whole idea is to help people in the beginning
or the end of the day,
either recovery at the end of the day, so yin,
or in the beginning of the day,
just kind of set you up for the best ski day.
And if you're a skier
and you haven't done yoga before skiing,
it will change your life
because you just feel like a different human being.
You just feel ready.
Right on man, we did it.
We kept it under three hours.
Yesterday at this time,
I thought there's no way we're gonna be able to talk
for more than 45 minutes.
Really?
I go through this every, every time.
Imposter syndrome.
A little bit of that.
Also just a sense of being like unprepared.
But then look at us, we read a climate report.
We did.
You feel good?
Me?
I feel good.
I feel verified.
You are, I verify you.
You have a blue check in my heart.
Oh, thanks man.
That's all that matters, mostly.
Ted, thank you for dropping in.
I appreciate it.
Absolutely, thanks for having me.
Thank everybody for listening.
I don't take your attention for granted.
Again you can follow Adam @adamskolnick.
I'm @richroll on all the stuff.
If you'd like to send us a question
for consideration on the show,
leave us a message at 424-235-4626.
You can check out the show notes
on the episode page at richroll.com
we'll have links to all the stuff
that we talked about today and that's it.
I wanna thank everybody who helped put on today's show.
Jason Camiolo for audio engineering,
production show notes, interstitial music,
all kinds of behind the scenes stuff.
Blake Curtis for videoing the show.
We got a new team member,
I pointed out Dan Drake is in the house.
He's gonna be doing lots of video stuff
and all kinds of other,
you have to be determined stuff.
So welcome Dan to the RRP.
Jessica Miranda for graphics,
David Greenberg for taking portraits today,
Georgia Whaley for copywriting.
We got our boy DK on advertiser relationships
and theme music as always by Tyler,
Trapper and Eric, my boys.
I appreciate the love you guys,
see you back here soon.
Until then, peace.
And congrats to Jason, 400th episode today.
Is that right?
Yes.
I didn't know that.
Thank you, Jason.
He is the OG of this organization.
Thanks, Jason, namaste.
I feel like Ted should say that.
Namaste everyone.
(upbeat music)